At Miele, our partner is the planet. Our appliances use less water and energy, and our tests last the equivalent of 20 years of use. That's the ultimate form of sustainability. I'm Nelson Fresco, President and CEO of Miele Canada. Until June 30th, every purchase of a Miele dishwasher or laundry machine supports the preservation and restoration of Canadian forests through the Miele Forest Initiative. Join us in making an impact today for a better tomorrow. Visit Miele.ca to learn more.
在美诺（Miele），我们的合伙人是地球。我们的家电用水量和耗电量更少，并且我们的测试相当于20年的使用寿命。这就是可持续发展的终极形式。我是美诺加拿大公司总裁兼首席执行官尼尔森·弗雷斯科。截至6月30日，购买美诺洗碗机或洗衣机的每一笔消费，都将通过“美诺森林倡议”支持加拿大森林的保护与恢复。加入我们，共创今日之影响力，以造福更美好的明天。访问 Miele.ca 了解更多信息。
This is a Reese's Peanut Butter Cub sound experiment. We're looking to find the perfect way to hear Reese's so you'll buy more of them. Here we go. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Hey, get out of here, you little stinker. Reese's. Reese's.
这是一个好时花生酱杯的声音实验。我们正在寻找倾听好时的完美方式，这样你就会买更多。我们开始吧。好时。好时。好时。好时。好时。好时。好时。好时。嘿，滚开，你这个小调皮。好时。好时。
Reese's. Peanut butter cups. That breathy one sounded very creepy, am I right? Welcome back to the second drink of Michael's birthday. We've got some fun stuff to share before our breakdown begins. We went into our candy bag alts and found an alt Jim Talking Head that would have come at the very top of the episode and it really sums up how Michael feels about his birthday. Here's what Jim said,
好时。花生酱杯。那个带喘息声的听起来真诡异，对吧？欢迎回到迈克尔生日的第二杯特饮。在我们的深度剖析开始之前，我们有一些有趣的内容要分享。我们翻看了我们的糖果袋备选，发现了一个吉姆的“对着镜头说话”备选镜头，它本应该出现在剧集的最开头，这真的很总结迈克尔对他的生日的感受。吉姆是这么说的：
Michael makes a pretty big deal out of his birthday. A couple of years ago, it fell on a Saturday. So we observed it on a Friday, and again the following Monday. I mean, we kind of do this, lady. We kind of now celebrate our birthdays, like, for a week. Birthday week. It's birthday week. This is starting to happen. This is a thing. I see this all the time on the gram.
迈克尔对他的生日非常重视。几年前，它落在了星期六。所以我们在星期五庆祝了一次，然后在接下来的星期一又庆祝了一次。我的意思是，我们有点这样做，女士。我们现在有点像庆祝我们的生日，持续一周。生日周。这就是生日周。这开始发生了。这是一回事。我在网上经常看到这个。
Oh, you do? Oh, yeah. I think we just do it because we celebrate here at work and then we celebrate with our families and then we go for a birthday walk together. I love it. We have lots of little traditions that requires multiple celebrations.
哦，是吗？哦，是的。我想我们这样做只是因为我们在工作时庆祝，然后和家人庆祝，然后一起去进行生日散步。我太喜欢了。我们有很多小传统，需要进行多次庆祝。
I'm with Michael on this one. I also went to the season two DVD for this episode and I found a treasure trove I was not expecting in the bonus features. Okay, there are a whole list of fakey PSAs. Yeah. Yeah. I know we talked a little bit about this when Steve did one,
在这点上我和迈克尔站在同一边。我还翻看了这一集的第二季DVD，并且在花絮中发现了一个我没料到的宝藏。好吧，这里有一整串虚假的公益广告。是的。是的。我知道我们之前稍微聊过一点这个，当史蒂夫拍过一个的时候，
but there's a series of them with you, Jenna, Rain and John. There are 10. Can I? What? Yes, there are 10 of them on. There are 10. Can I relate? Yes, there are 10 of them on this one particular DVD. I have no memory of this. Here is a list of- I'm in them?
但是有一系列这样的广告，是你，珍娜，雷恩和约翰。有10个。我能吗？什么？是的，有10个。有10个。我能关联吗？是的，这上面有10个。我对这个毫无记忆。这里有一份清单——我在里面吗？
Yes, I'm gonna play some for you. Here is a list of the PSA titles, ready? Okay, public service announcements. Remember, these used to play on television for the young children. And these are like satire, these are fakie. These are fakie. Okay, all right, here's a list. for the young children. And these are like satire. These are fakie. These are fakie. Okay.
是的，我要给你们放几个。这是一份公益广告的标题清单，准备好了吗？好的，公益广告。记住，这些以前是在电视上放给小孩子们看的。这些就像是讽刺，这些是假的。这些是假的。好吧，好吧，这是一份清单。放给小孩子们看的。这些就像是讽刺。这些是假的。这些是假的。好吧。
All right. Here's a list. Meteor, smell, invite, cake, foul, jelly beans, fugitive, saltine, thumb, and Arctic wolf. Do any of those ring a bell for you? Nothing. Nothing. No recall of any kind.
好吧。这是一份清单。流星、气味、邀请、蛋糕、犯规、果冻豆、逃犯、苏打饼干、大拇指和北极狼。这些里面有哪个能唤起你的回忆吗？什么都没有。什么都没有。没有任何记忆。
All right. Well, I think I'll play two of them today. And you know what? I'm going to start just sprinkling these into second kind. All right. Well, I think I'll play two of them today. And you know what? I'm going to start just sprinkling these into second drinks. All right. So first up, let's hear the PSA for smell. People may laugh at you when you put the word smell into everyday phrases like smell you later or smello. But I promise you, it's not funny.
好吧。嗯，我想我今天要放两个。你知道吗？我正准备把这些随手穿插进第二杯里。好吧。嗯，我想我今天要放两个。你知道吗？我正准备把这些随手穿插进第二杯里。好吧，那么首先，让我们听听关于“气味”的公益广告。当你把“气味”这个词放进日常短语里时，人们可能会嘲笑你，比如“回头见”或者“气味儿”。但我向你保证，这一点都不好笑。
And they're just being nice to you because you maybe are their boss. I don't remember, that's literally me talking. I know, and if you watch it, you're so earnest. All right, okay, next one I'm gonna play for you is Arctic Wolf. Is this Rainn Wilson by any chance? Yeah. Okay. The Arctic Wolf lives on this Rainn Wilson by any chance? Yeah.
而且他们对你好只是因为你可能是他们的老板。我不记得了，那简直就是我在说话。我知道，而且如果你看的话，你显得那么认真。好吧，好的，接下来我要放给你的是北极狼。这碰巧是雷恩·威尔逊吗？是的。好吧。北极狼生活在这个雷恩·威尔逊身上吗？是的。
Okay. The Arctic Wolf lives on a diet of caribou, musk oxen, lemmings, and hairs. I could do that if I had to. I mean, what were these for? I don't know, but I'm gonna start sharing them every once in a while. Well, I can't wait to hear more of those.
好吧。北极狼以驯牛、麝牛、旅鼠和野兔为食。如果必须的话，我也能做到。我的意思是，这些到底是用来干什么的？我不知道，但我打算每隔一段时间就分享它们一次。嗯，我等不及要听更多这些内容了。
I love this idea. All right, everyone, well, here is our breakdown of Michael's birthday. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch
我喜欢这个主意。好了，各位，这就是我们对迈克尔生日的深度剖析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做“办公室终极重温”
podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Happy birthday, everybody. It is Michael's birthday. Michael, it's your B day.
播客，专为你打造。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能为你讲述的独家幕后故事。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能为你讲述的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。祝大家生日快乐。今天是迈克尔的生日。迈克尔，今天是你的B日。
Oh my gosh. Oh, Angela, he would be so happy if anyone responded to his birthday like that. Yeah, this guy needs a party like nobody else. He needs the party. It's so true guys. It's season two, episode 19, Michael's birthday written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky directed by Ken Whittingham.
噢天哪。哦，安吉拉，如果有人那样回应他的生日，他会高兴坏的。是的，这家伙比任何人都更需要一个派对。他需要这个派对。真的太对了，伙计们。这是第二季第19集，迈克尔的生日，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯特普尼斯基编剧，肯·惠廷汉姆执导。
Guys, I'm in my closet right now. I am in my that's what She Shed. This morning, my husband figured out how to try to soundproof it, Sam. I don't know if we did it. We tried, but we got a shower curtain out of the guest room and Josh put it across the shed and hung some blankets on it. We took, you know, the clamps that our kids have a fort building kit. Wow. And we took all of their clamps. So I hope the kids don't get to do a fort this week because mom is trying to podcast from home.
伙计们，我现在在我的衣帽间里。我在我的“那正是她的小屋”里。今天早上，我的丈夫弄清楚了如何试着给它做隔音，山姆。我不知道我们成功了没有。我们试过了，但我们从客房里拿了一条浴缸帘子，乔许把它横挂在小屋上，还挂了一些毯子。我们拿了，你知道的，我们孩子们玩的那种建堡垒套件的夹子。哇。我们拿了他们所有的夹子。所以我希望孩子们这周别想搭堡垒了，因为妈妈正试图在家里录播客。
The best part of seeing you right now on this video chat while we do this is that you are wearing a set of gamer headphones. Yes, I am. I have a giant microphone, but I've pointed it up to the sky. Like an antenna coming out of your ear. Yeah, that's true. And we're gonna put a photo of this on the pod. Should I do a summary? Here it is. Do a summary, babe. I don't know why I called you, babe. I don't know. I don't know either. Do a summary, babe. It's Michael's birthday and he is desperate to be the center of attention.
你现在在这个视频聊天里看着我录制这一段时，最棒的部分是你戴着一副游戏玩家耳机。是的，我戴着。我有一个巨大的麦克风，但我把它指着天空。就像一根从你耳朵里长出来的天线。是的，没错。我们会在播客里放一张这个的照片。我应该做一个总结吗？在这儿呢。做一个总结，宝贝。我不知道我为什么叫你宝贝。我不知道。我也不知道。做一个总结，宝贝。今天是迈克尔的生日，他极度渴望成为人们关注的焦点。
Meanwhile, we learn that Kevin is waiting for the results of a mole biopsy. Yes. Kevin is very worried. He might have skin cancer and this is causing a distraction to Michael's birthday that he is unhappy with. Oh my gosh. Michael's like, today is the day. Oh my gosh, Michael's like, today is the day for celebration
与此同时，我们得知凯文在等待一个痣活检的结果。是的。凯文非常担心。他可能患有皮肤癌，这分散了迈克尔对生日的注意力，对此他不高兴。哦天哪。迈克尔就像是在说，今天就是这一天。哦天哪，迈克尔就像是在说，今天是庆祝的日子，
and you guys are all worried about Kevin and I am grumpy about it. Yeah. That's my summary. I like it, babe. Babe, I like it. Babe. Okay, wait, are we just gonna jump right in?
而你们都在担心凯文，我对这很不爽。是的。这就是我的总结。我喜欢它，宝贝。宝贝，我喜欢。宝贝。好吧，等等，我们要直接跳进去吗？
No, there's more summary. And fast facts, you've forgotten everything. Wow. There's more summary. And fast facts, you've forgotten everything. Wow. There's more summary. What is happening? Also in this episode, Dwight and Angela really bicker over who exactly is in charge of planning Michael's birthday party.
不，还有更多总结。还有快讯，你把什么都忘了。哇。还有更多总结。还有快讯，你把什么都忘了。哇。还有更多总结。发生什么事了？在这集中，德怀特和安吉拉真的为了到底谁负责策划迈克尔的生日派对而争吵不休。
Is it Dwight as his right-hand man or is it Angela, head of the PPC? This is the first time we're gonna see a little tension going on between Dwangela. Yeah. Well, I mean, there was tension in season one over who was the security officer, you know. That was pre them dating.
是作为他得力干将的德怀特，还是PPC（派对策划委员会）负责人安吉拉？这是我们第一次看到“德怀拉”之间出现一点紧张气氛。好吧，我的意思是，第一季里关于谁是保安主管就存在紧张气氛，你知道的。那是他们约会之前的事。
So they have some issues about who gets to have control of what. They had that going into this relationship and I have a note card guys that says, DWANGELESS SASS! Ooh, DWANGELESS SASS! All through this episode. We're gonna track it. Also in this episode, Jim and Pam, they sneak out of the office together
所以他们对于谁来控制什么有一些分歧。他们带着这种状况进入了这段关系，我有一张便签，伙计们，上面写着：“德怀拉式的傲慢！”哦，“德怀拉式的傲慢！”贯穿这一集。我们要追踪它。还有在这集中，吉姆和帕姆，他们一起溜出了办公室，
and in the end, the entire office gang is going to go ice skating. Who saw that coming? I didn't see that coming. Well, the writers knew that we were gonna end up at an ice skating rink. That leads me into, Sam, please play my special audio clip. Fast facts! What is that? What is happening?
最后，整个办公室的一帮人都要去滑冰。谁能料到这一点？我没有料到这一点。好吧，编剧们知道我们最后会去到一个溜冰场。这引导我进入，山姆，请播放我的特别音频剪辑。快讯！那是什么？发生什么事了？
We had a fan submit some little, they're called stings, Angela. I love that so much. I didn't even know there was such a thing. Yeah. Thank you. So more stings please. More stings guys, send us your stings. I didn't even know that was a term. We're learning so much. We're a hundred, but thank you for making us stings.
我们有一个粉丝提交了一些小片段，它们被称为“短音效”，安吉拉。我太喜欢了。我甚至不知道还有这种东西。是的。谢谢。所以请来更多短音效。更多短音效，伙计们，把你们的短音效发给我们。我甚至不知道那是一个术语。我们学到了好多。我们已经一百岁了，但谢谢你们给我们制作短音效。
So fast fact number one is that Steve Carell is a very, very good ice skater. He played hockey growing up. He played pick-up hockey every week as an adult. Fan question from Matt Loveless, was the plot built around Steve's ability to ice skate? Yes. He's so good. He's really good. Yes.
所以快讯第一条是，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是一个非常非常好的溜冰者。他从小打曲棍球。他成年后每周都打野球。来自马特·洛夫莱斯的粉丝提问：剧情是围绕史蒂夫的溜冰能力构建的吗？是的。他太棒了。他真的很棒。是的。
The writers had on one of their cards up on the wall this fact about Steve being a good ice skater and they had been looking forever for a way to incorporate it. And you guys might remember that later when we filmed the threat level Midnight, that again, that plot of threat level Midnight, midnight the movie takes place in an ice skating rink and That was just like another opportunity to feature Steve's ice skating ability
编剧们把关于史蒂夫很会溜冰这个事实写在了墙上的一张卡片上，他们一直在无休止地寻找一种方法把它融入进去。你们可能还记得，后来当我们拍摄《午夜危机》时，那个《午夜危机》电影的剧情再次发生在溜冰场里，这就像是另一个展示史蒂夫溜冰能力的绝佳机会。
I was at the car wash one time waiting for my car to get washed, right? You know the one you kind of you can drive through part of it and then you wait on the other side, right? Yeah, so I'm at the car wash and this guy walks up to me and goes, I ice skate with Steve. Just, you know, sometimes I ice skate with Steve. And I was like, oh, what? Oh, okay, well, way to go. You're probably very good,
我有一次在洗车行等我的车被洗，对吧？你知道那种你可以把车开进其中一部分，然后你在另一边等的洗车行，对吧？是的，所以我正在洗车行，这个家伙朝我走过来，说：“我跟史蒂夫一起溜冰。”就是，你知道的，“有时候我和史蒂夫一起溜冰。”然后我就想，哦，什么？哦，好吧，真厉害。你可能非常厉害，
cause Steve is good, have a nice day. Well, you know, Angela, my husband Lee ice skates. He's on several pickup hockey teams and my son as well is a hockey player. And my husband now plays on the pickup team that Steve used to play on. I wonder if he plays with the guy from the car wash. Steve does not play pickup hockey anymore.
因为史蒂夫很厉害，祝你有美好的一天。好吧，你知道的，安吉拉，我的丈夫李会溜冰。他参加了好几个野球冰球队，我的儿子也是一名曲棍球运动员。而且我丈夫现在加入了他以前史蒂夫打过的那个野球队。我想知道他是不是和那个在洗车行遇到的人一起打球。史蒂夫不再打野球了。
He told me he kind of retired from that. But back when we shot this episode, he was really into it. He was really into it. And Jenna, you're like a hockey mom. I have been on the ice with you now and I've met your hockey mom friends and I am into it. I don't have a kid that plays hockey, but they told me you can drink beer at like 10 a.m. hockey matches. And I'm like, I think this is the crowd I should be in. I mean, I'm over at the soccer field. They got nothing at that concession stand. Maybe some pretzels. I mean, we're at these hockey rinks sometimes at seven in the morning or eight in the morning and they open up that concession stand and they go for it. I am not
他告诉我他已经算是退役了。但当我们拍这一集的时候，他真的很热衷于此。他真的很热衷于此。而且珍娜，你就像是一个曲棍球妈妈。我现在已经和你一起上过冰面了，我还见过了你的曲棍球妈妈朋友们，我也迷上这个了。我没有一个打曲棍球的孩子，但他们告诉我，你可以在早上10点的曲棍球比赛时喝啤酒。然后我就想，我觉得这就是我应该加入的圈子。我的意思是，我在足球场那边。那个小卖部里什么都没有。也许有些蝴蝶饼。我的意思是，我们有时早上七点或八点就在这些溜冰场，他们打开那个小卖部，他们就开喝了。我不是
a beer drinker, but I am amazed at people's ability to have a glass of beer in the morning. I'm like, that would do me in. But yeah, oh God, I love the hockey community. It's a great, great community. I love being a part of it. All right, fast fact number two. This is a fan question from Renata. She said, this episode has several external locations.
一个爱喝酒的人，但我对人们在早晨喝一杯啤酒的能力感到惊叹。我想，那会把我给整垮的。但是，天哪，我爱曲棍球社区。这是一个非常非常棒的社区。我很高兴能成为其中的一部分。好吧，快讯第二条。这是一个来自雷娜塔的粉丝提问。她说，这一集有几个外景。
Did it take longer to produce this episode because of that? So we usually would take five days to shoot an episode and we were still able to shoot this episode in five days, even with our multiple locations. And guess what I did, Angela? What? I got some scoop from Kentopedia about our locations. Kent's a born act, let's hear it.
因为这个，制作这一集花的时间更长吗？所以我们通常拍一集需要五天时间，而且我们甚至还能在五天内拍完这一集，尽管我们有多个外景。你猜我做了什么，安吉拉？什么？我从肯托百科（Kentopedia）那里打听到了一些关于我们外景的独家内幕。肯是个老手，让我们听听。
All right, so first up, the store that Jim and Pam go to was a Rite Aid at Woodman and Sherman Way. Do you remember that Rite Aid, Angela? I do. I do. I pass by it every day on the way to work and I would shop there constantly. Yeah.
好吧，首先，吉姆和帕姆去的那个商店是位于伍德曼路和谢尔曼大道交汇处的一家莱德（Rite Aid）。你还记得那个莱德吗，安吉拉？我记得。我记得。我每天上班路上都会路过它，我经常在那里购物。是的。
I would always like pick up some milk on the way home. One time I bought some socks. I was low on socks. Oh, I remember setting up my trailer. You know, we would sort of decorate and I got a few different little things. I got like a doormat at that Rite Aid. Okay, so cute.
我总是在回家的路上顺便买点牛奶。有一次我买了一些袜子。我的袜子快不够穿了。哦，我记得布置我的房车。你知道的，我们会稍微装饰一下，我弄了几个不同的小物件。我在那个莱德买了一个门垫。好的，太可爱了。
You were at the Rite Aid by us. He said that we shot there for a half a day, but we started very, very early. I think my hair and makeup started around 4 a.m. or 4 30 a.m. I believe it. Because, yeah, we had to start shooting on camera by six and the Rite Aid said we could only shoot there until 11 a.m. with the store closed. After 11 a.m. we could keep shooting, but they were going to let customers in. And Kent said that we finished by 10 a.m., we could keep shooting, but they were gonna let customers in.
你在我们附近的莱德。他说我们在那里拍了半天，但我们开始得非常非常早。我想我的发型和化妆大约在凌晨4点或4点半开始。我完全相信。因为，是的，我们必须在六点前开始在镜头前拍摄，而且莱德说我们只能在那里拍到上午11点，那时商店是关门的。11点之后我们可以继续拍，但他们要让顾客进来了。肯说我们在10点前就拍完了，我们可以在10点前继续拍，但他们要让顾客进来了。
And Kent said that we finished by 10 a.m., we finished an hour early, and that all the customers that you see in those scenes are hired background performers, none of them are real customers. All right? Good job, team, good job. You got in, you got out.
肯说我们在10点前就拍完了，我们比预计提前了一个小时完成，你在那些场景中看到的所有的顾客都是雇来的背景演员，他们没有一个是真正的顾客。好啦？干得好，团队，干得好。你们进去了，你们出来了。
That's the scoop on the Rite Aid. So the ice skating, we shot that at Pickwick Ice Rink in Burbank. I know this rink well. And we had the whole place to ourselves for one full day. We were there from 7 a.m. to 7 p.m. Again, we started our hair and makeup very early, around 5 a.m. and we were all shooting by 7.
这就是关于莱德的内幕。所以滑冰那部分，我们在伯班克的皮克wick冰场拍摄的。我非常熟悉这个冰场。我们一整天都包下了整个地方。我们在那里从早上7点待到晚上7点。同样，我们很早就开始做发型和化妆，大约早上5点，我们7点就开始拍摄了。
The other skaters in the background were background actors. We shut that place down. It was all ours. So Kent also told me that luckily both Randall Einhorn and Matt Sohn, they were our camera operators that they could ice skate. And so they were skating around with cameras. Do you remember that Angela?
背景中的其他溜冰者都是背景演员。我们把那个地方清场了。它全归我们了。所以肯还告诉我，幸运的是，兰德尔·艾因霍恩和马特·索恩，他们是我们的摄像师，他们都会溜冰。所以他们带着摄像机在周围滑来滑去。你还记得吗，安吉拉？
Cause I did not remember that those guys were skating around with cameras. Do you remember that Angela? Because I did not remember that those guys were skating with us. I remember Randall on the ice. I do because I have a little funny backstory about there was a stunt ice skater, Jenna. Do you remember the stunt ice skater? Oh yeah, the guy who filled in for Oscar. Yes, so you'll see later in the episode as we watch it that Oscar is like a very good ice skater. He does like a kind of a pirouette and spins around. Well, that's because there was a stunt guy that looked like him that was a really great figure skater. And I have a little story about that. I don't know if you remember this, Jenna, but Randall was
因为我不记得那些家伙带着摄像机滑来滑去。你还记得吗，安吉拉？因为我不记得那些家伙带着摄像机和我们一起滑了。我记得兰德尔在冰上。我记得，因为我有一个小趣闻，就是当时有一个替身溜冰演员，珍娜。你记得那个替身溜冰演员吗？哦，是的，那个代替奥斯卡的家伙。是的，所以你会在稍后的剧集中看到，当我们观看它时，奥斯卡就像是一个非常好的溜冰者。他做了一个类似芭蕾旋转的动作，转圈圈。好吧，那是因为有一个长得很像他的替身，他是一个非常棒的花样滑冰运动员。我有一个关于这个的小故事。我不知道你是否还记得这个，珍娜，但当时兰德尔在
filming the stunt guy getting all of the moves, right? Yeah. And they wanted us skating in the background and I sort of skated in the background and I did a big circle. Like I kind of opened my legs and did a big circle. And the guy said to me in between takes, he goes, hey, he said, can you skate? And I was like, well, I can roller skate. So I'm just trying to do what I do on roller skates.
拍摄替身演员做出所有动作，对吧？是的。他们想让我们在背景里滑冰，我有点在背景里滑冰，我还转了一个大圈。就像我有点叉开腿转了一个大圈。那个家伙在两场拍摄的间隙对我说，他说，嘿，他说，“你会溜冰吗？”然后我说，嗯，我会溜旱冰。所以我只是在尽量做我在旱冰上做的事。
And he said, come here. And he spun me around. And then Randall was like, oh wait, I'll get this just in case. Maybe it'll be funny that Oscar spins Angela or something. You know? Okay. And so the stunt ice skater started doing all these things with me, Jenna. He spun me, he picked me up and twirled me. He had me stick one leg out and one leg up, like, like, and then, and like, spun me and set me down. And we, like, somewhere there is footage of this stunt ice skater lifting me in the air and spinning me around.
他说，“过来。”然后他把我转了一圈。接着兰德尔就像是，哦等等，我把这个拍下来以防万一。也许奥斯卡转安吉拉什么的会很有趣。你知道吗？好的。于是那个替身溜冰演员开始和我一起做所有这些动作，珍娜。他旋转我，他把我抱起来转圈。他让我一条腿伸直，另一条腿抬起，就像，就像，然后，把我转了转，放我下来。我们，就像，某个地方有这个替身溜冰演员把我举在空中转圈的录像。
And it, we never- Where is this footage? We never used the footage, but it, it really made me laugh to think that maybe there is a world where Angela and Oscar figure skate together. Okay, two things. Number one, NBC released this footage immediately. Number two, Angela, do you know who that guy was? I looked him up. Tell me, tell me. Okay, his name is Burt Jude Lankin.
而且它，我们从来没有——这段录像在哪里？我们从来没有用过这段录像，但它真的让我大笑，去想象也许存在这样一个世界，安吉拉和奥斯卡一起花样滑冰。好吧，两件事。第一，NBC立刻发布了这段录像。第二，安吉拉，你知道那家伙是谁吗？我查过他。告诉我，告诉我。好吧，他的名字叫伯特·朱德·兰金。
Okay. And he was a pair skater, a famous pair skater who won the silver medal at the 1982 United States Figure Skating Championships and then later placed sixth at the 1984 Winter Olympic Games. Wow! You were figure skating with an Olympic pair figure skater! Where is this footage?
好吧。他是一名双人滑选手，一个著名的双人滑选手，曾在1982年美国花样滑冰锦标赛上获得银牌，后来在1984年冬季奥运会上获得第六名。哇！你和一个奥运会双人花样滑冰选手一起花样滑冰！这段录像在哪里？
That is amazing! That is so cool! Well, you know, I'm not very good That is amazing. That is so cool. Well, you know, I'm not very good, but he was very good. So well, I'm going to find the footage for you. I'm going to surprise you with it at some milestone birthday in the future. You'll have to ask Randall Einhorn.
这太令人惊叹了！这太酷了！好吧，你知道的，我不是很擅长——这太令人惊叹了。这太酷了！好吧，你知道的，我不是很擅长，但他非常擅长。好吧，我要帮你找到这段录像。在未来的某个里程碑式的生日上，我要用它给你一个惊喜。你得去问问兰德尔·艾因霍恩。
Say Randall, did any of that end up somewhere? Oh, my gosh. OK, well, next up is FastFact number three. Did any of that like end up somewhere? Oh my gosh. Okay. Well, next up is fast fact number three, but I don't even know how to follow that because that was good stuff. Picture me and Oscar right now in your mind, guys. Close your eyes. Picture me and Oscar right now as a figure skating couple on the ice and go.
说，兰德尔，那些有任何片段流落到什么地方了吗？噢，天哪。好吧，接下来是快讯第三条。其中有任何片段流落到什么地方了吗？噢，天哪。好吧，接下来是快讯第三条，但我甚至不知道该怎么接下去，因为那真是太棒的内容了。现在在你们脑海里想象我和奥斯卡，伙计们。闭上眼睛。想象我和奥斯卡此刻作为冰上一对花样滑冰伴侣，开始。
Oscar makes all of our costumes. Well, Angela, that is a good segue for me into fast fact number three, cause you mentioned costumes. We got a fan question from Alyssa and this is not specific to this episode, but a general fan question and I thought it was a good one.
奥斯卡制作了我们所有的服装。好吧，安吉拉，这对我来说是一个很好的过渡，切入快讯第三条，因为你提到了服装。我们收到了一个来自艾丽莎的粉丝提问，这并不是针对这一集的，而是一个普遍的粉丝问题，我觉得这是一个好问题。
So I thought we would include it. Alyssa wants to know, what do you do with your clothes after you've been shooting in the same outfit for 12 to 15 hours at a time? She says I imagine they would get stretched out and wrinkly and dirty. Do you have multiple sets of the same outfits for each day of shooting or does someone wash them for you? First of all, I like where her head's at. Yeah. I like this person.
所以我想我们应该把它包含进来。艾丽莎想知道，当你穿着同一套衣服一次拍摄12到15个小时后，你如何处理你的衣服？她说我想象它们会变得又松垮、又起皱又脏。对于每一天的拍摄，你们有多套相同的衣服，还是有人帮你们洗？首先，我喜欢她的思维方式。是的。我喜欢这个人。
I know. This person is a planner. She probably packs very well for a trip. I like it. I like your train of thought. These are things I wonder about when I watch movies, especially if I see a movie where like it's a flood or they're submerged in water somehow, I think,
我知道。这个人是个做计划的人。她去旅行时可能行李收拾得很好。我喜欢。我喜欢你的思路。这些是我看电影时会好奇的事情，尤其是如果我看到一部电影，比如里面有洪水，或者他们不知怎么浸在水里，我在想，
oh my gosh, how many hours that day did they have to stand like waist deep in water? Probably like 12 hours. So here's the thing. We often had, well, we always had duplicates. They wanted to make sure that you had two of every outfit so they could wash and have the next set ready the next day. Also if you were to spill something on it or get a tear or whatever they would have the duplicate ready to go. Yes and if you did have to do some sort of a stunt or something in that particular outfit then
哦天哪，那天他们得在齐腰深的水里站多少个小时？大概12个小时吧。所以情况是这样的。我们通常有，嗯，我们总是有复本。他们想确保你每套衣服都有两套，这样他们就可以清洗并在第二天准备好下一套。此外，如果你不小心把东西洒在上面或者撕破了什么的，他们就会有准备好的复本。是的，如果你确实得在那套特定的衣服里做某种特技或者什么，那么
they might have even more than two. You know, they might have seven shirts if part of the scene involves you purposely dripping ketchup on your shirt or something. So yeah, they always had multiples. And part of the wardrobe department's job is to launder and prepare your outfit for the next day. So that's how that works. I like the question though. I like the question. All right. That's the end of my fast facts. Oh, I'm so sorry guys. My what the **** was that? Well, I think my bread is done. I have some bread in the oven. I thought that was like an alert. Like they always say you can tell a little something about the person by which alarm they pick.
他们甚至可能会有超过两套。你知道的，如果场景的一部分涉及你故意把番茄酱滴在衬衫上什么的，他们可能会有七件衬衫。所以，是的，他们总是准备多件。服装部门的工作之一就是清洗并为第二天准备你的衣服。这就是它的运作方式。不过我喜欢这个问题。我喜欢这个问题。好啦。这就是我的快讯的结束。哦，我很抱歉，伙计们。我那算什么鬼东西？嗯，我想我的面包烤好了。我烤箱里有一些面包。我以为那是一个闹钟。就像他们总说的，你可以通过一个人选择哪个闹钟来了解他的一点事情。
And by they I mean me. This is my theory. So like your alarm is like gang, gang, gang, like mayday, mayday. And like my alarm is like two banjos playing. Ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding Do you mind if we take a break? I do want to take a break because my That's What She Shed is really cold. And I turned my heater off when we podcast and I want to warm it back up. So you take care of your bread, you heat up your bread. I'm going to heat up my she shed and we'll be right back.
他们指的是我。这是我的理论。所以就像你的闹钟是那种，铛，铛，铛，就像“五月天，五月天”（求救求救），而我的闹钟就像是两把班卓琴在弹奏。叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮，你可以按一个按钮就加入一个会议，这能帮助你把治疗融入你繁忙的生活中。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与一位有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。你的身心健康很值得。如果你正考虑开始心理治疗，你可以尝试一下BetterHelp。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So here's how it works. With BetterHelp, you can pay a flat fee for weekly sessions and that's going to save you big time on cost and time because therapy should feel accessible and with online therapy you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and has served over 5 million people globally. And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Your wellbeing is worth it. And if you are thinking of starting therapy, you can give BetterHelp a try.
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。以下是它的运作方式：通过 BetterHelp，您可以为每周的咨询支付固定费用，这能在时间和金钱上为您节省大量成本，因为心理治疗本该是触手可及的。通过在线心理治疗，您能以合理的价位获得优质的护理。BetterHelp 拥有超过 3万 名治疗师，是全球最大的在线心理治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供过服务。而且它非常便捷，只需点击一下按钮即可加入咨询，帮助您将心理治疗融入繁忙的生活中。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与持有执照的治疗师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。您的身心健康非常值得投入。如果您正考虑开始心理治疗，不妨尝试一下 BetterHelp。
Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Okay, Martin, let's try one. Remember, big. You got it. The Ford It's a Big Deal event is on. How's that? A little bigger. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Nice. Now the offer? Lease a 2025 Escape Active all-wheel drive
访问 betterhelp.com 斜杠 office ladies 今天就可以在你的第一个月享受10%的折扣。那就是 BetterHelp，H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。好吧，马丁，我们来试一个。记住，要宏大。明白了。福特“这是一个大事件”活动正在进行中。觉得怎么样？再大一点。福特“这是一个大事件”活动。很好。现在是优惠部分？租赁一辆2025款翼虎（Escape）Active全轮驱动版，
from 198 bi-weekly at 1.99% APR for 36 months with $27.55 down. Wow, that's like $99 a week. Yeah, it's a big deal. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Visit your Toronto area Ford store or Ford.ca today. Well, I just oversaw the bread. We're still not at the right internal temperature. I had to leave it for Lee to make a judgment call.
双周付198起，年利率1.99%，期限36个月，首付2755。哇，那大概是一周99块钱吧。是的，这是一件大事。福特“这是一个大事件”活动。今天就访问您多伦多地区的福特商店或 Ford.ca。好吧，我刚才把面包烤过头了。我们仍然没有达到正确的内部温度。我不得不把它留给李来做出判断。
I hope it turns out. I hope we can make some sandwiches today. Time will tell. Let's get back on track, Jenna, and let's jump into this episode. Yes, the cold open. Michael is trying to sell the employees some calling cards. Mm-hmm. Did you notice something about this scene, Jenna?
我希望它能烤好。我希望我们今天能做一些三明治。时间会证明一切。让我们回到正轨，珍娜，让我们切入这一集。是的，冷开场。迈克尔正试图向员工们兜售一些电话卡。嗯哼。你注意到这个场景的一些细节了吗，珍娜？
It's in the conference room, right? Yep. Yeah. Who all is in attendance? Who? It is Jim. Dwight. Jim, Dwight, Toby, Creed, Oscar, Ryan, and Stanley. Not a single woman. Hey. Hey. Now do you think A, Michael thinks the women will say, this is a load of crap, but he thinks the guys will go along with it? Why aren't there any women? Hmm? Hmm.
它是在会议室里，对吧？没错。是的。都有谁出席了？谁？有吉姆。德怀特。吉姆、德怀特、托比、克里德、奥斯卡、瑞恩和斯坦利。没有一个女性。嘿。嘿。现在你觉得A，迈克尔认为女性会说，“这纯属扯淡”，但他认为男性会顺从它？为什么没有女性呢？嗯？嗯。
Hmm. Jim convinces Michael that this is a pyramid scheme. Michael draws a chart, and then Jim turns it into a literal pyramid. Do you remember in the fire episode when Michael said he lost all of his money in a pyramid scheme and that's why he couldn't go to business school? Yeah, Toby brings it up in this scene. Yeah.
嗯。吉姆说服迈克尔这是一个传销骗局。迈克尔画了一张图表，然后吉姆把它变成了一个字面意义上的金字塔。你还记得在火灾那一集里，迈克尔说他在一个传销骗局中失去了所有的钱，这就是为什么他不能去商学院吗？是的，托比在这场戏里提到了这一点。是的。
Toby's like, remember? Well, Toby brings up an email scam that Michael also participated in. Yes, and Michael's like, hey, when the son of the deposed king of Nigeria emails you directly asking you for help, his father ran the frickin country okay yeah Michael Michael Michael all right so that's our cold open and then when the episode begins that was one of those standalone cold opens that did not end up applying I have one more question about the cold open you might know the answer oh go ahead is a calling card the same as a business card? What Angela? What's a calling
托比就像是，还记得吗？嗯，托比提到了迈克尔也参与过的一个电子邮件诈骗。是的，迈克尔就像是，嘿，当被废黜的尼日利亚国王的儿子直接发电子邮件向你求助时，他父亲可是统治着那个该死的国家的，好吧，是的，迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，好吧，这就是我们的冷开场，然后当剧集开始时，那是那些最终没有实际应用的独立冷开场之一。关于冷开场我还有一个问题，你可能知道答案，哦，请说，电话卡和名片是一回事吗？什么，安吉拉？什么是电话
card? Wait, no, you're not asking this question. Do you not remember the 80s? Honey, I was in Indi. Oh, I just called you honey. I'm a baby, I'm a honey. Honey, I was in Jakarta, Indonesia till 1984. What happened? What's the calling card? Okay, gosh, how do I describe it? You know how long distance phone calls, they would cost money, like so much money per minute, if you wanted to call someone
卡？等等，你不是在问这个问题吧？你不记得80年代了吗？亲爱的，我在印尼。哦，我刚才叫你亲爱的。我是个宝贝，我是个亲爱的。亲爱的，我1984年之前一直都在印度尼西亚雅加达。发生了什么？什么是电话卡？好吧，天哪，我该怎么描述它呢？你知道长途电话，它们要花钱，比如每分钟花好多钱，如果你想给某人打电话，
and you would usually just use your home phone and then I can't believe I'm describing this right now. Wait, so it's like a card with a number on it and you enter it or something? And then you can't believe I'm describing this right now. Okay. Oh, so it's like a card with a number on it and you enter it or something? And then you use the minutes? Yes, it's like a prepaid credit card that you could apply to the price of a phone call. Okay, I know what it is now.
你通常只会用你家的座机，然后，我不敢相信我正在描述这个。等等，所以它就像是一张上面有数字的卡片，你输入它什么的？然后你就可以，我不敢相信我正在描述这个。好吧。哦，所以它就像是一张上面有数字的卡片，你输入它什么的？然后你就可以使用通话分钟数？是的，它就像是一张预付费信用卡，你可以把它用在电话费上。好吧，我现在知道了。
I got it. I remember that for whatever reason in my mind, I thought this whole scene was about business cards and I thought it was really funny. Oh, Ann. That's funny. So anyway, and I was like, oh, look, they're making their own business cards. That's kind of cute. No, no.
我懂了。我记得不知出于什么原因，在我的脑海里，我以为整场戏都是关于名片的，而且我觉得这真的很好笑。哦，安。真搞笑。所以无论如何，当时我就想，哦，看，他们正在制作自己的名片。那挺可爱的。不，不。
You don't need Phil and his corvette for that. Now this makes sense. Yeah. Okay. I hear the tone in your voice, Jenna. I hear it. I don't know how to end this. I hear the tone in your voice, Jenna. I hear it. I hear it. I hear it. It's like you pity me, but you love me, but you're perplexed that a grown woman doesn't know what a calling card is. I hear it all. It's all there. But I love you. Okay. So they weren't business cards. They were calling cards. All right. I love you,. I love you babe. I love you honey. Go. That was the cold open. It was a standalone cold open, right? It doesn't apply to the rest
你不需要菲尔和他的科尔维特来做那个。现在这就说得通了。是的。好吧，我听出了你声音里的语调，珍娜。我听出来了。我不知道该怎么结束这个。我听出了你声音里的语调，珍娜。我听出来了。我听出来了。我听出来了。这就像你在同情我，但你又爱我，但你对一个成年女性竟然不知道什么是电话卡感到困惑。我都听出来了。全都在那儿了。但我爱你。好吧。所以它们不是名片。它们是电话卡。好吧。我爱你，。我爱你，宝贝。我爱你，亲爱的。走吧。那是冷开场。那是一个独立的冷开场，对吧？它并不适用于其余部分
of the episode because after the credits we're gonna learn the real plot of this episode when Michael enters and Pam, while handing him his messages for the day,, happy birthday, Michael. When he enters, he's carrying his own box of donuts for his birthday. Is he carrying the balloons that we're going to see later in his office? Probably. I couldn't track where the balloons came from. But then Michael has a talking head where he tells us
的剧集，因为在片头之后，我们将了解到这一集的真实剧情，当迈克尔进来时，帕姆一边递给他当天的留言，一边说，“生日快乐，迈克尔。”当他进来时，他正拿着他自己买的一盒甜甜圈来过生日。他拿着我们稍后会在他办公室里看到的那些气球吗？很可能。我无法追踪那些气球是从哪里来的。但接着迈克尔有一个对着镜头说话的镜头，他告诉我们
that people go crazy for his birthday. They just go all out. They go all out. And it's just a boring shot of the office, just everyone doing work. Yeah. No one paying attention. And then Jenna, he says that he shares a birthday with Eva Longoria. And I looked up her birthday.
人们为他的生日疯狂。他们简直全力以赴。他们全力以赴。而镜头切到一个无聊的办公室空镜头，每个人都在工作。是的。没有人理会他。然后珍娜，他说他和伊娃·朗格利亚同一天生日。我查了她的生日。
It's March 15. Jenna, yours is March 7th. Yeah. That means you and Michael Scott are both Pisces. We're both Pisces. Which I also looked up. And this was what I found on the internets about Pisces. You, Jenna Fisher, and Michael Scott. Are you ready? I'm ready. In all matters of life, you bring intensity and passion. This explains why you will devote an endless amount of time and effort into anything that
是3月15日。珍娜，你的是3月7日。是的。这意味着你和迈克尔·斯科特都是双鱼座。我们都是双鱼座。我也查了这一点。这就是我在互联网上关于双鱼座的发现。你，珍娜·费舍尔，还有迈克尔·斯科特。准备好了吗？我准备好了。在生活的方方面面，你都带来强度和激情。这就解释了为什么你会将无尽的时间和精力投入到任何你觉得
you feel is worthwhile, especially family and loved ones. Hey! I know! That sounds like a compliment. I think it is. You are giving me a compliment. I am giving you a compliment. Thank you.
值得的事情中，尤其是家庭和挚爱。嘿！我知道！听起来像个夸奖。我想是的。你是在夸我。我是在夸你。谢谢。
So now Jim has a talking head. Well, wait, wait, wait. Before we get to that, I think something really important happens here, which is Kevin is late for work. Now, we don't know why yet, but he's late. He seems a little preoccupied. And when he walks in, Michael's like, you're late, but you're forgiven because Doth, it is my birthday. This has made me laugh. because Doth, it is my birthday. This has made me laugh. Michael's such an idiot. I love him.
所以现在吉姆有了一个对着镜头说话的镜头。好吧，等等，等等，等等。在我们谈到那个之前，我觉得这里发生了一件非常重要的事情，那就是凯文上班迟到了。现在，我们还不知道为什么，但他迟到了。他看起来有点心神不定。当他走进来时，迈克尔就像是，你迟到了，但你被原谅了，因为，呃，今天是我的生日。这把我逗笑了。因为，呃，今天是我的生日。这把我逗笑了。迈克尔真是个笨蛋。我爱他。
But yes, Kevin is late. So, and then we go to Jim's talking head. Well, here's something I wanna say about Jim's talking head. So the meat of the talking head is he's just kind of describing what Michael is like on his birthday. But look at the winter backdrop behind him. So you know how we- You love this. You love this so much. You you know how we love this.
但是是的，凯文迟到了。所以，然后我们切到吉姆对着镜头说话。好吧，关于吉姆对着镜头说话，我有一点要说。所以这段独白的核心是他只是在描述迈克尔在生日这天是什么样的。但看看他身后的冬日背景。所以你知道我们——你太喜欢这个了。你太喜欢这个了。你你知道我们有多喜欢这个。
You know I love our backdrops. OK, so that's not a real window to the outside. That's just a window to a printed backdrop that we would change seasonally. And I just noticed that the backdrop is winter. It looks like it's maybe snowy. And I'm going to bring this up later. So put a pin in that,
你知道我爱我们的背景。好吧，所以那不是通往室外的真正窗户。那只是通往印有季节性更换背景的窗户。我刚注意到那个背景是冬天的。看起来可能是下雪了。我待会儿会提起这个，所以把这个记在心里，
but I just wanna say winter backdrop behind Jim. I am riveted. Okay? I am riveted. Yeah. I cannot wait. Oh, it's gonna pay off later. Big time. I cannot wait for this payoff. Big time. Of the winter backdrop. Yeah. All right, so then we see Meredith and Kevin
但我只想说吉姆身后的冬日背景。我被迷住了。好吧？我被迷住了。是的。我等不及了。哦，待会儿会有回报的。大大的。我等不及这个回报了。大大的。冬日背景的。好吧，那么我们看到梅雷迪思和凯文
in the break room, and she says, "'Did you hear anything yet?' And so we start to see like what's happening with Kevin, right, that he might have a skin cancer scare. Yeah. And this storyline starts. And then we go to Dwight in Michael's office. There is no one more excited for Michael's birthday
在茶水间里，她说：“你听到什么消息了吗？”所以我们开始看到凯文身上发生了什么，对吧，他可能遭遇了皮肤癌的虚惊一场。是的。这个故事情节开始了。然后我们来到迈克尔办公室里的德怀特。没有人比德怀特更对迈克尔的生日感到兴奋了，
than Dwight, really. I mean, it is such a special day for him. It is a huge day. If only everyone were reacting like Dwight, Michael would be happy. Michael reveals he's wearing a new suit. He says it's from Italy. No, Bulgaria. Right.
真的。我的意思是，对他来说这是如此特殊的一天。这是极其重大的一天。如果每个人都像德怀特那样反应，迈克尔就会很高兴了。迈克尔透露他穿着一套新西装。他说那是来自意大利的。不，保加利亚的。对。
A new suit. And Dwight said maybe he'll have to get one. And Michael's like, good luck. It's pinstriped, I noticed. And the tie is insane. It's a crazy tie as well. This is also the scene where Michael tells Dwight that he's not worried about his birthday because the PPC has been working 24-7 since yesterday. But also it's in the scene that Dwight actually begs Michael if he can be in charge of Michael's birthday. So this is setting up like what's
一套新西装。德怀特说也许他也得去买一套。迈克尔就像是，祝你好运。我注意到它是细条纹的。领带也很疯狂。这也是一条疯狂的领带。这也是迈克尔告诉德怀特他不用担心他的生日的场景，因为PPC从昨天开始就一直在24小时连轴转。但也是在这个场景中，德怀特实际上恳求迈克尔让他负责迈克尔的生日。所以这在铺垫就像什么
going to be a big source of tension between Angela and Dwight. And I think Angela, you know, thinks that Michael's an idiot and thinks that Dwight is loyal to someone who doesn't deserve like his loyalty. And so she's just already, she already is like annoyed that it's Michael's birthday. And now on top of the fact her boyfriend wants to be the party planning, you know, committee chairman. Well, Angela must be very conflicted because as party planning committee head, she is obligated to celebrate this birthday.
安吉拉和德怀特之间将产生巨大的紧张关系。我认为安吉拉觉得迈克尔是个白痴，并且认为德怀特对一个根本不值得他忠诚的人效忠。所以她已经很不高兴今天是迈克尔的生日了。现在再加上她的男友想当派对策划委员会的主席。好吧，安吉拉一定内心非常纠结，因为作为派对策划委员会的负责人，她有义务庆祝这个生日。
Yes, yes. Even though she feels that Michael is kind of going a little bit over the top, right? Mm-hmm. Yes. Well, Ange, the next scene is the party planning committee scene. One more thing before we move on. There is a famous meme that came out of this Dwight and Michael scene. It is the raise the roof.
是的，是的。尽管她觉得迈克尔有点做得过火了，对吧？嗯，是的。好吧，安吉，下一场戏就是派对策划委员会的戏了。在继续之前还有一件事。这个德怀特和迈克尔的场景中有一个著名的表情包。就是那个“举起房顶”。
Oh, the raise the roof, yes. Yes. Yes. And in the... Super famous meme. It's even longer in the deleted scenes, you guys. So if you check out the deleted scenes, it's really funny because when Dwight starts to do it, Michael's like, no, that's not how I taught you.
哦，“举起房顶”，是的。是的。是的。而且在……超级著名的表情包。你们知道，在删减片段里甚至更长。所以如果你去看删减片段，真的非常搞笑，因为当德怀特开始做那个动作时，迈克尔就说，不，我不是这么教你的。
I should like, like clearly they've practiced this move. Oh, I love that. I love that there's an extra deleted scene of that raise the roof. Well, next up is the party planning committee meeting. Lady, it's the OG. It's the OG. It is Phyllis, Angela, and Pam. That's it. Baby, I don't know what an OG is. Do you call me baby? I did. That's what it is today. It's OG. Jenna,
我应该……很显然他们排练过这个动作。哦，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢关于那个“举起房顶”的额外删减片段了。好吧，接下来是派对策划委员会的会议。女士，这是元老级（OG）。这是元老级（OG）。就是菲利斯、安吉拉和帕姆。就这些。宝贝，我不知道什么是OG。你叫我宝贝吗？我叫了。今天它就是这个意思。这就是OG。珍娜，
okay, get on the internet, lady. What is it? You might know what a calling card is, but let me tell you what OG is. It means original gangster, original gangster. It's like you are the first person of this thing, whatever. I don't know. Look it up on Urban Dictionary. So it's the OG of the PPC. Oh, I want a hoodie that says OG of the PPC. Note to self. That'd be great. Oh, look at the coffee mug I'm using. I'm using the OG PPC. Oh you're using the PPC coffee mug today. Yay. That's apropos. That's another word Angela. Apropos. I know what that means. It means appropriate. Yeah I got it. Okay. All right so they're having a riveting conversation in this meeting. They want to know what time we should bring out the cake. One or one thirty. And Pam. One or 1.30. And Pam yawns.
好吧，上网查查吧，女士。它是什么？你可能知道什么是名片（calling card），但让我告诉你什么是OG。它的意思是原创黑帮（original gangster），原创黑帮。就像你是这件事情的始祖一样，不管是什么。我不知道。在城市词典上查一下。所以它是PPC（派对策划委员会）的元老。哦，我想要一件印有“PPC元老”字样的连帽衫。提醒自己。那会很棒。哦，看看我用的咖啡杯。我用的是PPC元老杯。哦，你今天在用PPC咖啡杯。耶。这很贴切。又是一个词，安吉拉。贴切（Apropos）。我知道那是什么意思。意思是恰当。是的，我懂了。好吧。好吧，所以他们在这次会议上进行了一场扣人心弦的对话。他们想知道我们应该在几点把蛋糕拿出来。一点或者一点半。还有帕姆。一点或者一点半。然后帕姆打了个哈欠。
Oh, wait. Pam yawns. Pam says 1 o'clock, to which Angela immediately says 1.30. And then Pam yawns. Yeah. And then Angela sasses her. Yeah. She's like, oh, I'm sorry.
哦，等等。帕姆打哈欠。帕姆说一点钟，安吉拉紧接着说一点半。然后帕姆打了个哈欠。是的。然后安吉拉对她冷嘲热讽。是的。她说，哦，不好意思。
Are we boring you? Well, you know, there's in a deleted scene, I improvised a line where I said, not fill us. Yes. Do you remember that? I do. I do. And then we all laughed. We used to laugh a lot when we did these PPC scenes.
我们无聊到你了吗？你知道的，在删减片段里，我即兴说了一句台词，我说，菲利斯除外。是的。你还记得吗？我记得。我记得。然后我们都笑了。我们拍这些PPC的戏时以前经常笑个不停。
Well, they would let us go. They would give us a few lines and then they would just let us go. And we would improvise the most boring, conversations like on purpose we'd be like well I don't know guys how I feel about paper plates I mean which size should we get should we get the large oval one no one gets oval who gets an oval paper plate no one I think we get the square one square paper plates we would like we would do this for like so long. That's because Greg Daniels loved the PPC.
好吧，他们会让我们自由发挥。他们会给我们几句台词，然后就让我们自己演。我们会故意即兴发挥出最无聊的对话，比如我们会说，好吧，伙计们，我不知道我对纸盘有什么看法，我是说我们应该买多大尺寸的，我们应该买大椭圆的吗？没有人用椭圆的，谁会用椭圆的纸盘？没有人。我觉得我们应该买正方形的，正方形的纸盘……我们会像这样演好久。那是因为格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）非常喜欢PPC。
I know. He loved our mundane banter so much. He loved the dynamic of it. And so he would let us just go on forever. I loved it. Yes, it was so fun. Well, then Dwight enters and he tells us that Michael wants trick candles for his cake.
我知道。他太喜欢我们那些世俗的闲聊了。他很喜欢这种化学反应。所以他总是让我们滔滔不绝。我很喜欢。是的，太有趣了。然后德怀特进来了，他告诉我们迈克尔想要整蛊蜡烛放在他的蛋糕里。
Yeah, he gives us a list, a list of surprises that Michael would like. And this is when Angela tells Dwight that this is a closed-door meeting. Well, yeah, Michael wants trick candles. He wants a stripper gram. And Angela's like, no, no, it's a closed-door meeting. And then there's this sort of odd like stare off between Dwight and Angela. And Pam was like, what is happening? Yes. I have a fan catch as well. What? This is a fan catch from sexually woke. This person wrote in to say, Phyllis is breaking at four minutes, 19 seconds. When you
是的，他给我们列了一个清单，迈克尔想要的惊喜清单。就在这个时候，安吉拉告诉德怀特这是一场闭门会议。好吧，是的，迈克尔想要整蛊蜡烛。他想要一个脱衣舞电报。安吉拉就说，不，不，这是一场闭门会议。然后德怀特和安吉拉之间有一种奇怪的对视。帕姆就说，发生什么事了？是的。我也有一个粉丝发现的细节。什么？这是来自“性觉醒（sexually woke）”粉丝的发现。这个人写信说，菲利斯在四分钟十九秒的时候笑场了。当你们
talk about the strip of gram, I did not notice this the first time I watched it, and I saw it. She gets a little smirk. And I think you could think it was Phyllis the character, but Angela, we know Phyllis, and I think this was a real Phyllis smile. I'm sure it was. We laughed a lot in those scenes.
谈到脱衣舞电报时，我第一次看的时候没有注意到，但我看到了。她露出了一个狡黠的微笑。我想你可能会觉得那是角色菲利斯，但安吉拉，我们了解菲利斯，我觉得这是一个真正的菲利斯的微笑。我确信是的。我们在那些戏里笑了很多次。
So I love that. I'm gonna go back and look for that. That's so cute. I also wanna note that when Rain comes in and out of the door, John is not at his desk in the background. So he bailed on some background work. Way to go, John. Way to be sneaky and get out of that scene. I know. I guess what was he? He was probably playing Madden football in his trailer with Brian or something. Yes, they were playing Madden football. That's what they would do in their downtime when they had scenes.
所以我很喜欢那个。我要回去找找看。太可爱了。我还想指出的是，当雷恩进出门口时，约翰在背景里并不在他的办公桌旁。所以他逃掉了部分背景工作。干得好，约翰。真狡猾，逃掉了那场戏。我知道。我猜他在干嘛？他可能在跟布莱恩或者什么人在他的房车里玩麦登橄榄球（Madden football）。是的，他们在玩麦登橄榄球。他们在有空闲时间拍戏时就会那样做。
And they would yell. They were so loud. Do you remember? They were so loud. They'd be like, get it! Get him! All right, so at four minutes, 35 seconds, we now have this phone call between Michael and Jan in Michael's office.
而且他们会大喊大叫。他们声音太大了。你还记得吗？他们声音太大了。他们会喊：拿到它！抓住他！好吧，所以在四分钟三十五秒时，迈克尔办公室里现在有了迈克尔和简之间的这通电话。
Yeah. And Jenna, did you catch who is in the room with Michael? Ryan. Ryan is sitting there for the whole phone call. And the call is so awkward. He's like, hey, I called to wish you a happy birthday. And she's like, it's not my birthday. And he's like, oh, I thought we had the same birthday. And she's like, no.
是的。珍娜，你发现谁和迈克尔在同一个房间里了吗？瑞恩。瑞恩坐在那里听完了整通电话。而且这通电话太尴尬了。他说，嘿，我打电话来祝你生日快乐。简说，这不是我的生日。他说，哦，我以为我们同一天生日呢。简说，不是。
And then she's like, happy birthday, Michael. And then she's like, are we being filmed? And he's like, nope, not at all. And then he says, Jan, just feel free to say whatever is in your heart. And then doesn't she just like hang up? Click dial tone. And the whole time Ryan is sitting here and I have a little something to point out. If you go and watch the deleted scenes, there is a beginning to this scene.
然后她说，生日快乐，迈克尔。然后她说，我们正在被拍摄吗？他说，不，完全没有。然后他说，简，有什么心里话尽管说出来。然后她是不是直接挂断了？挂断，拨号音。整个过程瑞恩都坐在那里，我有一个小细节要指出。如果你去看删减片段，这个场景其实有个开头。
And that is that Ryan, the temp has been given the task to tie those balloons in Michael's office. Oh, this is where the balloons come from. Yeah, so him and Michael are in his office. Ryan is tying a balloon to like his chair and then he's like, can I leave? And Michael's like, nope. Thank you so much for telling me this. Because I was wondering, where did those dang balloons come
那就是临时工瑞恩被派去给迈克尔办公室的气球系上绳子。哦，这就是那些气球的来源。是的，所以他和迈克尔在办公室里。瑞恩把一个气球系在他的椅子上，然后他说，我可以离开吗？迈克尔说，不。非常感谢你告诉我这件事。因为我一直在想，那些该死的气球是从哪里来的？
from? Because Michael did not walk in with them. He must have somehow ordered Ryan the temp to get them. Yes. And then he makes him. And this deleted scene is the proof. He makes them stay in for the phone call. Oh, god.
因为迈克尔进来时并没有带着它们。他肯定不知怎么命令临时工瑞恩去弄来的。是的。然后他强迫他。这段删减片段就是证据。他让他们留下来听电话。哦，天哪。
It's so miserable. I feel so bad for Ryan in that scene. Well, the next scene is very cringy as well, because Michael's in the kitchen, and he is just hovering over this box of donuts, waiting for someone. And then when Stanley comes in, he's like, oh my gosh, somebody must have brought in donuts for my birthday.
太惨了。我在那个场景里真为瑞恩感到难过。好吧，接下来的场景也非常尴尬，因为迈克尔在厨房里，他一直在那盒甜甜圈旁边徘徊，等待着某个人。然后当斯坦利进来时，他说，哦天哪，肯定有人为了我的生日买甜甜圈了。
Michael, we saw you carry that box in when you arrived. Michael. Somebody? Michael. Michael. Michael, we saw you carry that box in when you arrived. Michael. Somebody, Michael. Michael, Michael, Michael, Michael. I have something to point out here. So you know in Booze Cruise, you and Jim look at each other for 27 seconds of silence, right?
迈克尔，我们看着你到达时把那个盒子搬进来的。迈克尔。某个人？迈克尔。迈克尔。迈克尔，我们看着你到达时把那个盒子搬进来的。迈克尔。某个人，迈克尔。迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔。我这里有一点要指出。所以你知道在《游艇派对》里，你和吉姆在27秒的沉默中互相对视，对吧？
Yeah. 27 seconds. Is that right? 27 seconds, that's right. Okay, I want you to know how long Michael stood with his hand on that coffee pot, waiting for someone to come in so he could act like he was pouring himself a cup of coffee, act surprised that there were donuts for his birthday. He stood there for 10 seconds of pure silence.
是的。27秒。是这样吗？27秒，没错。好吧，我想让你知道迈克尔把手搭在那个咖啡壶上站了多久，等着有人进来，这样他就可以假装自己在给自己倒杯咖啡，假装惊讶地发现有为了他生日准备的甜甜圈。他在绝对的沉默中站了整整10秒钟。
Wow. Now, if you think about a TV show, you guys, that's like a long time to leave a character just sitting there waiting for someone to notice him. That is so true. That's amazing. Ten seconds. Ten seconds he stood there looking around waiting for someone to walk in. And then later when Toby comes in, it's so sad.
哇。现在，如果你想想一部电视剧，伙计们，让一个角色傻傻地站在那里等着别人注意到他，这算是很长的时间了。确实如此。太惊人了。十秒钟。他站在那里东张西望，等着有人走进来，整整十秒钟。然后后来托比进来时，太让人难过了。
Toby sees the donuts and he finds out it's Michael's birthday and he gives the most just upbeat and warm. Genuine. Happy birthday. Happy birthday, Michael. Yeah. And then Michael is so mean. Michael's like, you didn't remember? Well, yeah, I guess I'm not going to remember to give you a donut. I know. He's such a turd to Toby. And Toby was being so nice to him. I know. So also happening in this episode is everyone kind of learning about the fact
托比看到了甜甜圈，他发现今天是迈克尔的生日，于是他给出了最乐观、最温暖的祝贺。真诚的。生日快乐。生日快乐，迈克尔。是的。然后迈克尔太刻薄了。迈克尔说，你没记住？好吧，是的，我想我也不会记得给你一个甜甜圈。我知道。他对托比太混蛋了。而托比对他是那么好。我知道。这一集里还在发生的另一件事是，每个人都开始知道了
that Kevin's waiting for these skin test results. So like Jim's in the break room, and they're talking about it, and Kelly overhears. Yeah. Kelly, you mean Mindy. Mindy overhears. That is a Mindy Kaling talking head. When she's like, oh my gosh, I never thought about death until Princess Diana's funeral, which was so sad. And then she pauses and she's like, that and my sisters? Like, oh, it's such a dark, it's such a dark talking head. It's so dark.
凯文在等待皮肤检查结果这件事。所以像吉姆在茶水间，他们正在谈论这事，凯利无意中听到了。是的。凯利，你是说明迪。明迪无意中听到了。那是明迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）的单人采访。当时她说，哦天哪，我从来没有想过死亡，直到戴安娜王妃的葬礼，太令人伤心了。然后她停顿了一下说，还有我姐姐们？就像，哦，太黑暗了，这是一个多么黑暗的单人采访。太黑暗了。
I don't know how Mindy got through that. She almost didn't. I want you to know, look at six minutes, five seconds. Mindy is so about to laugh. She's barely holding it together. Well, then the accounting department is discussing Kevin's possible skin cancer, Angela. And you are, I mean, Angela Martin is a real downer.
我不知道明迪是怎么撑过那一段的。她差点没撑过去。我想让你们知道，看看六分钟零五秒。明迪快要笑出来了。她快要憋不住了。好吧，然后会计部门正在讨论凯文可能患有皮肤癌的事，安吉拉。而你，我是说安吉拉·马丁是个十足的扫兴鬼。
She's a little bit of Debbie Downer. I mean, Oscar's like, you know what? I'm sure it's going to be fine. I'm like, don't give him false hope. You don't know that. Is that pragmatic? I think she is, you know, yeah, she's pragmatic. She doesn't need to see the rosy picture.
她有点像个扫兴鬼（Debbie Downer）。我是说，奥斯卡说，你知道吗？我确信会没事的。我就说，别给他虚假的希望。你又不知道。这难道是务实吗？我觉得她是，你知道的，是的，她很务实。她不需要去看那些粉饰太平的美好画面。
She's like, just give me the stats. Yeah, what are the stats on this? need to see the rosy picture. She's like, just give me the stats. Yeah, what are the stats on this? The stats are you should be worried. Yeah, that's what the stats say. So next up, Michael gets a delivery. Oh man. But he thinks that the woman is his strip-o-gram. He's so excited. He's giddy. He literally says, here we go. And then he has a line that made me laugh so hard. He's like, Oh,
她会说，直接把数据告诉我。是的，这上面的数据是什么？不需要去看那些粉饰太平的美好画面。她会说，直接把数据告诉我。是的，这上面的数据是什么？数据就是你应该担心。是的，数据就是这么说的。所以接下来，迈克尔收到了一件快递。哦天哪。但他以为那个女人是他的脱衣舞电报女郎。他太兴奋了。他兴高采烈。他字面意思上说，我们开始吧。然后他说了一句让我笑得前仰后合的台词。他说，哦，
this chair has arms. Is that going to be all right? I loved that line that made me laugh so hard. He's like, it'll be fine. It'll probably, you'll work around it. I feel like Steve improvised that. I feel like he improvised that. I don't know. I don't know, but I bet you're right. I do. I wish I had the script for this one because I would look it up, but I feel like that feels like, that feels like something you notice in the moment.
这椅子有扶手。这样可以吗？我太喜欢那句台词了，把我笑惨了。他说，没关系。可能，你能克服的。我觉得史蒂夫那是即兴发挥的。我觉得那是他即兴发挥的。我不知道。我不知道，但我敢打赌你是对的。确实。我真希望我有这一集的剧本，因为我会去查一下，但我觉得那感觉，感觉就像是你当场注意到的东西。
Right, because they just pulled the chair aside, and it had arms, and I think he saw it in the moment, and he set it. That's what I, it feels very much like a Steve improv moment. Well, I do want to just give a shout out to this guest actor, Susan Foley, who played the delivery woman.
对，因为他们刚好把椅子拉到一边，而它有扶手，我觉得他当时就看到了，然后说了出来。这就是我所……这非常像是史蒂夫的即兴发挥时刻。好吧，我只是想对这位客串演员苏珊·弗利（Susan Foley）表示感谢，她在剧中饰演快递员。
I thought she was great. She was fantastic. She played it super straight, super real, made it very, very funny. Her confusion was not overplayed. It was perfection. Well done, Susan. And then we just find out some sad backstory
我觉得她演得太棒了。她太出色了。她演得非常正经，非常真实，把这一段变得非常非常搞笑。她的困惑并没有过度夸张。简直是完美。干得漂亮，苏珊。然后我们了解到了迈克尔童年的一些悲惨背景。
of Michael's childhood. Jenna, his childhood breaks my heart. It breaks my heart. So we had this birthday party when he was seven. He was so excited. He said they got a pony and a cart and the pony gave him a rash and his mom rubbed cream on him for three hours. And then he missed the party.
珍娜，他的童年让我心碎。让我心碎。所以他七岁时办过这个生日派对。他当时超级兴奋。他说他们弄来了一匹小马和一辆手推车，结果小马让他起了疹子，他妈妈给他抹了三个小时的药膏。然后他就错过了派对。
He said it was his worst birthday. Well, this is a runner and some of them got cut out, but Michael had this runner throughout this episode of all of his worst birthdays, comparing it to this one. So this guy has had a lot of bad birthdays. Well, he's going to get a pick me up from Dwight, who's going to play the recorder for him while he eats donuts. Dwight is playing Billy Joel, which is a runner on our show.
他说那是他最糟糕的生日。好吧，这是一个贯穿全剧的笑点（runner），虽然有些被剪掉了，但迈克尔在这一整集中都有这个他历年最糟糕生日的梗，并把它和这次作比较。所以这家伙经历过很多糟糕的生日。好吧，他将从德怀特那里得到一点安慰，德怀特会在他吃甜甜圈时为他演奏竖笛。德怀特吹的是比利·乔尔（Billy Joel）的歌，这也是我们剧里的一个常驻梗。
We're constantly going to the Billy Joel Music Library on The Office. I don't know why that is. For the longest time. Of course, Dwight calls him William Joel. And then Michael is just sort of lamenting how he's being treated in The Office. And he says, I bet Luke Perry's friends don't treat him like this. Wait. And he references this poster that this is what the delivery
我们在《办公室》里经常使用比利·乔尔的音乐库。我不知道为什么会这样。持续了很长时间。当然，德怀特叫他威廉·乔尔（William Joel）。然后迈克尔只是在发牢骚，抱怨他在办公室里受到的对待。他说，我敢说卢克·佩里（Luke Perry）的朋友们绝不会这样对待他。等等。他提到了这张海报，这就是那个快递
woman was delivering. It is a poster of James Dean, not of Luke Perry, that his mom sent him for his birthday. That's what his mom sent him. Now, do you think that his mom meant to send him Luke Perry, or she meant to send him James Dean, and Michael just mistook it for Luke Perry? Which one is Michael a fan of or neither? Is it just Michael's mom was like, I don't
员送来的东西。那是一张詹姆斯·迪恩（James Dean）的海报，而不是卢克·佩里的海报，那是他妈妈送给他的生日礼物。那就是他妈妈送给他的。现在，你觉得他妈妈是本打算送他卢克·佩里，还是本打算送他詹姆斯·迪恩，而迈克尔只是错把它当成了卢克·佩里？迈克尔是哪一个的粉丝，还是两个都不是？难道只是迈克尔的妈妈心想，我不知道
know what to give him. I think Michael is probably a fan of Luke Perry and that's who his mom thought it was. That's what I think. I think. I like that story. I don't know. But I mean, I feel like that's something my mom would do. Or my sister. When you're at Christmas, my sister got me a Green Bay Packers baseball hat. Yeah. And I was like, I don't get it. And she was like, well, you went to Baylor green and gold. Same colors. I was like, what? Same colors. Right. Same colors. Right. So I feel like that could be sort of a mom moment.
该送他什么好。我觉得迈克尔可能真的是卢克·佩里的粉丝，他妈妈以为那就是他。这就是我的想法。我觉得。我喜欢那个故事。我不知道。但是，我是说，我觉得那绝对是我妈会做的事。或者我姐姐。圣诞节的时候，我姐姐送了我一顶绿湾包装工队（Green Bay Packers）的棒球帽。是的。然后我说，我不明白。她说，哦，你去了贝勒大学（Baylor），绿色和金色。颜色一样。我说，什么？颜色一样。对。颜色一样。对。所以我觉得那挺像个妈妈会有的时刻。
Angela, one year for Christmas, my mom got me from, I guess, a local art fair in St. Louis, a drawing of a woman and her cat. She got it for me because she knows I love cats. I'm going to post this on Office Ladies pod Instagram. Is she gonna get upset with you? Is she gonna say something? No, this is a running joke in our family now. It is, Angela, it is a, it is a, I don't know how to describe it.
安吉拉，有一年圣诞节，我妈送了我一张画，我想大概是圣路易斯的一个当地艺术集市上买的，画的是一个女人和她的猫。她买给我是因为她知道我喜欢猫。我要把这个发到“办公室女士”播客的Instagram上。她会生你的气吗？她会说什么吗？不，这现在成了我们家里的一个老笑话了。是的，安吉拉，这是一个，这是一个，我不知道该怎么形容它。
It is a drawing of a woman on all fours. What? In lingerie. Nope. With her tush in the air. And the cat is rubbing seductively on the woman's tush. And your mom missed all that. She just thought it was a lady and her cat. Yes. So Angela, imagine me on Christmas morning. She hands me, I'm in like college when she gives me this. I come home from college, I unwrap this box,
这是一幅一个女人四肢着地的画。什么？穿着内衣。不是的。屁股翘在空中。而那只猫正充满诱惑地在那个女人的屁股上蹭来蹭去。而你妈妈错过了所有这些。她以为那只是一位女士和她的猫。是的。所以安吉拉，想象一下圣诞节早晨的我。她把这个递给我，我当时大概在上大学，她把这个送给我。我从大学回家，我拆开这个盒子，
and I'm looking at like a semi-pornographic drawing of a woman and her cat. Just like, mom, what is this present? And she goes, what do you mean? It's a lady who loves her cat. She loves that pussy so much. She's like, she loves, you love cats. And I'm like, Bob, I do love cats, but what is happening? And I, she didn't, she still like, didn't see it. She's like, I don't get it. My sister died laughing. I don't know if we've ever laughed so hard on Christmas ever in my family.
然后我看到的是一幅半色情风格的女人和猫的画。我就像，妈，这是什么礼物？她说，你什么意思？这是一个爱猫的女人。她太爱那个小猫咪（pussy）了。她说，她爱，你爱猫。我说，妈，我的确爱猫，但这是怎么回事？而且她没有，她依然没有看出来。她说，我不明白。我妹妹笑得前仰后合。我不知道我们全家在圣诞节有没有笑得这么疯狂过。
So now, here's, I still have it. Where is it? I'll tell you, I keep it in a drawer, but every time my parents come to my house and stay in my guest room, I get it out and I put it on the nightstand. And then there it is. And I'm like, Mom, where's your gift you gave me? And she knows that I do that. She knows that I don't keep it out all the time, but I like religiously, I put it out
所以现在，这里，我还留着它。它在哪里？我告诉你，我把它放在一个抽屉里，但每次我父母来我家住客房时，我都把它拿出来摆在床头柜上。然后它就在那儿了。然后我会说，妈，你送我的礼物在哪儿？她知道我这么做。她知道我并不是一直把它摆在外面，但我每次他们来拜访时，我都雷打不动地把它摆出来。
whenever they visit. And I will post a picture of it. I will post a picture of it. I love that story so much. I love it so much. That is something 100% that my dad would do. I have a story I will save for another one that my dad bought a painting from a man
而且我会把它的照片发出来。我会发一张照片的。我太喜欢那个故事了。我真的太喜欢了。那百分之百是我爸爸会做的事。我有个故事要留到以后讲，我爸从路边的一个人手里买了一幅画。我要留着它。因为那是情人节礼物。我要留着它。好吧，我们到哪儿了？德怀特走进员工开敞办公区，他宣布现在是上午11点23分，也就是迈克尔出生的确切时间，他建议大家把迈克尔连同椅子一起抬起来。
on the side of the road. I'm gonna save it. Cause it was a Valentine's gift. I'm gonna save it. Okay, where are we? Dwight goes into the bullpen and he announces that it is 11 23 a.m, the exact time of Michael's birth, and he suggests that everyone lift him up in his chair.
是的，这是一个传统。他们要把他高高抬起。这是一个传统。好吧，我在这里发现了一些东西。什么？我想让你看看这个场景背景里的菲利斯。在这个场景的最开始，
Yes, it's a tradition. They're gonna hoist him up in the air. It's a tradition. Well, I caught something here. What? I want you to look at Phyllis in the background of this scene. At the very beginning of the scene,
她在她电脑前的德怀特身后。而且我觉得导演在她说出“开始（action）”之前，她还没来得及清理她的电脑屏幕。是门（gates）吗？她在看大门吗？我不知道，因为她确实曾有一段时间深入研究过大门，为她的车道寻找一扇大门。我不知道。
she is behind Dwight at her computer. And I think that they said action before she had a chance to clear her computer screen. Is it gates? Is she looking at gates? I don't know, because she did go on a long deep dive where she would look for gates for a long time, a gate for her driveway. I don't know.
我真的很努力地放大看那是什么，但你必须看到的是，就在场景刚开始时，她把手举起来挡住了她屏幕上的东西，然后在八分钟53秒时，当迈克尔从办公室出来时，这是一个连续镜头。当你镜头切回菲利斯时，邓德米夫林的屏幕保护程序已经显示出来了。哦，她动作真快。她动作真快。是的，她把手举起来，用左手关闭了她刚才在做的事情。我对于我们的摄影师，伦纳德（Randall）或马特（Matt）说的话有着非常深刻的记忆：“嘿，菲利斯，我们能看到你屏幕上的大门。”因为她找了一整年的车道大门。
I really tried to zoom in and see what it was, but what you have to see is that right at the top of the scene, she puts her hand up to cover up whatever is on her screen and then at eight minutes, 53 seconds, when Michael comes out of his office, it's like a it's a continuous shot. When you come back to Phyllis, the Dunder Mifflin screensaver is up. Oh, she was quick. She was quick. Yeah, she she puts her hand up and with her left hand she's like closing out of whatever she was doing. I have such a vivid memory of our camera guys, Randall or Matt saying, Hey Phyllis, we can see the gates on your screen. Cause like for a year she looked at gates for her driveway.
哦，这让我大笑。好吧，就在这个时候，帕姆和吉姆在厨房里。他们没有参与把迈克尔抬起来的活动，帕姆向吉姆建议他们溜出去为凯文买点东西。是的。在10分钟33秒的时候，伙计们，我们知道了德怀特会给谁小费，不会给谁小费。我告诉你们吧，他给他的泌尿科医生小费。他自己没办法粉碎肾结石，他只给那些做着他自己做不了的工作的人小费。所以当三明治外卖员——顺便说一句，由贾斯汀·马洛尼（Justin Maloney）饰演——送来一堆潜艇三明治时，德怀特给他的都是正好的零钱，因为他本可以自己去送三明治的。
Oh, that makes me laugh. Well, it's at this point that Pam and Jim are in the kitchen. They are not participating in the hoisting of Michael and Pam suggests to Jim that they sneak out and buy something for Kevin. Yeah. At 10 minutes, 33 seconds, you guys, we learn who Dwight tips and who he doesn't. And let me tell you, he tips his urologist. He can't pulverize his own kidney stones and he only tips people who do jobs that he couldn't do himself. So when the sub delivery guy, who was played by Justin Maloney by the way, delivers a bunch of sub sandwiches, Dwight gives him exact change because he could have delivered his own subs.
他本可以的。他没去，但他本可以的。然后我们在茶水间发现，这些潜艇三明治是博洛尼亚香肠、番茄和番茄酱。是的。就这些。没有别的选项了。就是博洛尼亚香肠、番茄和番茄酱。
He could have. He didn't, but he could have. And then in the break room, we find out that these sub sandwiches are bologna, tomato, and ketchup. Yes. That's it. There's no other options. It's bologna, tomato, and ketchup.
那是什么？安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝提问。这是一个来自老头大卫（old man David）的粉丝提问。好吧。他想知道，你们当中有谁真的吃了那个可怕的潜艇三明治吗？我在立德（Rite Aid）药妆店。你还记得吗，有人吃过它们吗，它们真的是博洛尼亚香肠加番茄酱吗？老头大卫，不管那些三明治是什么，可能是剧组后勤部门（craft services）摆出来的，大家
What is that? Angela, we have a fan question. This is a fan question from old man David. Okay. He wanted to know, did any of you guys actually eat any of that horrible sub sandwich? I was at Rite Aid. Do you remember, did anyone eat them and were they actually bologna and ketchup? Old Man David, whatever those sandwiches were, were maybe set out by craft services and people
可能可以随便吃点。但我记不清演员或剧组人员吃过它们。但他们从来不浪费食物。如果他们拍戏用的食物是可以吃的，他们会把它摆在所有零食区的旁边，任何没有用完的东西，或者他们会送给剧组工作人员。所以如果我们有一场戏有很多生日蛋糕，如果他们没有用完那些蛋糕，他们会让人带回家。确实如此。也许我们把它们摆出来了，谁知道它们到底是什么呢。
could maybe snack on them. But I don't remember the cast or crew eating them. But they never let things go to waste. If they had food that was in a scene that was edible, they would set it out over by where all the snacks were, anything that wasn't used, or they would give them to crew members. So like if we had a scene where we had a bunch of birthday cakes, if they didn't use those birthday cakes, they would give them to people to take home. That's true. Maybe we set them out and who knows what they really were.
我们不知道。是的，也许它们是普通的三明治，但我的角色制止了任何人吃，因为她对这些三明治态度极其糟糕，她把迈克尔气得够呛，然后他把三明治打包好说，好吧，噎死你们算了。然后他径直走了出去。好吧，接下来，安吉拉，我们又看到了迈克尔关于他童年的另一个悲伤的单人采访。
We don't know. Yeah, maybe they were normal sandwiches, but my character kaboshes anyone eating because she's got a really crappy attitude about these sandwiches and she just makes Michael really mad and he packs them up and he's like, fine, choke on it. And he walks right out. Well, then Angela, we have another one of Michael's sad birthday talking heads about his childhood.
这一次他谈到自己16岁时，本该和一个叫朱莉（Julie）的同班同学去约会，但她却和班上另一个叫迈克尔的人去约会了，因为她没弄清楚自己究竟该跟哪个迈克尔去约会。他真的是有一整串……
This time he talks about being 16 years old and how he was supposed to go out on a date with a classmate named Julie, but she went out with a different Michael from his class instead, because she didn't realize which Michael she was supposed to go out with. He just has had a whole, yeah.
这是一个有趣的发现，安吉拉。在这个单人采访中，他说他第二天在学校里听大家议论了整整一天。好吧，你提到他的生日是3月15日。我为你准备了一个邓德百科（Dunderpedia）的发现。好的。他们算出迈克尔的16岁生日应该是1980年3月15日。那天是星期六。所以第二天将是星期日，迈克尔本不应该在学校里
Here's an interesting catch, Angela. In this talking head, he says he had to hear all about it the next day at school. Well, you mentioned that his birthday was March 15th. I have a Dunderpedia catch for you. Okay. They figured out that Michael's 16th birthday would have been March 15th, 1980. That was a Saturday. So the next day would have been Sunday and Michael wouldn't have been at school
听大家议论整整一天。搞什么鬼？什么？这是一个疯狂的发现。振作点。编剧室，你们振作点。我对找出这个事实的人有一种心心相惜的感觉，因为我花了45分钟在卡本代尔（Carbondale）找山药。哦对，你找了。你找了很长很长的时间。我找了。
to hear all about it. What the heck? What? That's a crazy catch. Get it together. Get it together, writer's room. I feel like a kinship with whoever figured out this fact because of the 45 minutes I spent trying to find yams in Carbondale. Oh yeah, you did. You looked for them for a long, long time. I did.
好吧，女士，你是双鱼座，你很激烈，充满激情。当某个话题打动我时，比如卡本代尔有山药吗？现在我们和吉姆和帕姆一起在立德（Rite Aid）药妆店。是的。格外调情。你们已经有一阵子没有那种让你们两个纯粹调情、疯狂调情的剧集了。所以我感觉对粉丝们来说，他们会超级兴奋，觉得哦，他们又开始了。他们又混在一起了。是的，他们给凯文买 了69杯杯面、一些M&M巧克力豆以及他最喜欢的电影《美国派2》。哦，天哪。
Well, lady, you're a Pisces, you're intense, and you're passionate. When the subject moves me, like are there yams in Carbondale? Now we're at the Rite Aid with Jim and Pam. Yeah. Extra flirty. You haven't really had an episode in a bit where you two got to be just like flirty, flirty. And so I feel like probably for fans, they were so excited to be like, oh, they're back at it again. They're in in cahoots. Yes, they bought 69 cup of noodles for Kevin, some M&M's and his favorite movie American Pie 2. Oh, man.
然后帕姆甚至还因为吉姆买了一些衣物柔顺剂而调侃他。哦，她说，你用衣物柔顺剂？我觉得她内心的独白是，哦，太可爱了。他自己洗衣服，还确保他的衣服软乎乎的。他以后一定会是个好丈夫。我爱他。你知道罗伊（Roy）才不会用什么衣物柔顺剂。罗伊根本不洗衣服。没错。好吧，接下来，安吉拉，是我整集中最喜欢的一个场景。没有
And then Pam even teases Jim for buying some fabric softener. Oh, she's like, you use fabric softener? And I feel like her internal monologue is like, oh, it's so cute. He does his laundry and he makes sure his clothes are soft. He's going to be a great husband. I love him. Well, you know Roy isn't using any fabric softener. Roy's not doing laundry. Exactly. Well, now next up, Angela, is my favorite scene from this whole episode. No
曲奇饼干。没有曲奇饼干。哦，你知道的，每当人们遇到我们时，总会跟我们说起某些台词。我总是听到“救救班迪（Save Bandit）”和“没有曲奇饼干”。好吧，德怀特和瑞恩在厨房里，安吉拉进来试图从德怀特手里抢走蛋糕，生日蛋糕，但德怀特就是不松手。但她可是派对策划委员会的负责人啊。把蛋糕拿出来是她的工作。是的。
cookie. No cookie. Oh, you know, we talk about things that people will say to us when they meet us. I get Save Bandit and I get no cookie. Well, Dwight and Ryan are in the kitchen and Angela enters and tries to take the cake, the birthday cake from Dwight, but Dwight won't let go of it. But she's the head of the party planning committee. It's her job to bring out the cake. Yes.
然后他们为这事起了点争执，接着德怀特说，嘿，稍后讨论财务状况的那个会议还开吗？安吉拉就说，行，行。但别指望有什么曲奇饼干。德怀特说，但如果我饿了呢？没有曲奇饼干。然后她就走了。接着是瑞恩的表情。瑞恩，哦，BJ，你的表情简直绝了，一副“我特么刚目睹了什么”的表情？
And they get in a little tiff about it and then Dwight says, hey, is that meeting to discuss finances still on for later? And Angela's like, fine, fine. But don't expect any cookie. And Dwight says, but what if I'm hungry? No cookie. And then she leaves. And then Ryan's Ryan's expression. Ryan, oh, BJ, your look is so fantastic of like, what the F did I
这到底是怎么回事？但接着他有一个无声的单人采访。所有这些，从那个场景开始直到他的单人采访结束的那分半钟左右的电视画面，简直是我这一集中最喜欢的片段。我太喜欢了。太棒了。BJ太棒了。这让整段戏都升华了。让它变得无比精彩，你知道吗？所以现在是祝迈克尔生日快乐。蛋糕端出来了。蜡烛点燃了。迈克尔要吹蜡烛了。与此同时，凯文接到了他的电话。是，是那个电话吗？
just witness? What is happening? But then he has that silent talking head. All of that, whatever that minute and a half of television is from the time that scene starts until the end of his talking head is just my favorite from this episode. I loved it. It's so good. BJ's so good. It like makes it. It makes it, you know? So now it's happy birthday to Michael. The cake is out. The candles are lit. Michael is going to blow out his candles. And at the same time, Kevin gets his phone call. Is it is it the phone call?
不，是斯黛西（Stacey）。斯黛西。他说那是斯黛西。迈克尔气坏了，因为他的蜡烛不是整蛊蜡烛，这时候每个人都在围着安慰凯文，迈克尔就说，你们够了，到底怎么回事？安吉拉非常尖锐地说，没人关心你的生日，迈克尔。是的，凯文在等检查自己有没有皮肤癌呢，迈克尔。这比这更重要。她简直是……直接把气氛降到冰点，我是说她直接粉碎了他希望拥有的任何好心情。好吧，女士，来自德兰妮（Delaney）和凯茜·奥黛尔（Cathy O'Dell）的粉丝评论，她们都说，我觉得所有人对迈克尔真的太苛刻了。
No it's Stacy. Stacy. He says it's Stacy. Michael is pissed because his candles aren't trick candles and this is when everyone's kind of hugging Kevin and Michael's like you guys stop what is going on? Angela says very pointedly no one cares about your birthday Michael yeah Kevin's waiting to hear if you have skin cancer Michael this is like this is more important she just like flattens it she I mean she just destroys whatever good mood he was hoping to have well lady fan comments from Delaney and Cathy O'Dell, they both said, I feel like everyone was really hard on Michael.
他不知道凯文的事，而且那是他的生日。他的反应真的有那么过分吗？好吧，事情是这样的。他表现得有点像个巨婴，但我觉得如果我们当中有任何人像作为同事那样真正关心他的话，应该有人在清晨把他拉到一边说，嘿，听着，凯文做了活检。情况是这样的。我们只是想让你知道。我们不知道你知不知道。是的。对。对。这样在当时那种情况下，他就不会
He didn't know about Kevin and it was his birthday. Is his reaction like really that out of line? Well, here's the thing. He's being a little bit of a baby, but I think if any of us really cared about him the way we should as his coworkers, someone should have pulled him aside early in the morning and said, Hey, listen, Kevin had this biopsy. Here's what's going on. We just want you to know. We don't know if you know. Yeah. Right. Right. So that in the moment he wouldn't be
表现得像个混蛋了，因为有人会把实情告诉他。现在，听着，他可能还是会觉得沮丧。他可能还是会花大量的精力试图让每个人都以某种方式庆祝他的生日。是的，他待会儿就会这么做了。好了，还记得我刚才告诉过你，在吉姆的单人采访背景里有一个冬天的场景吗？哦，这是前面的伏笔吗？快告诉我。我想让你注意到，在这个生日蜡烛场景的背景里，我的开衫正搭在椅背上。这是一个非常棒的细节，如果你注意到
such a jerk because someone would have let him in on it. Now, listen, he still would have been bummed. He still would have spent a ton of energy trying to make everyone like somehow find a way to be okay celebrating his birthday. Yeah, which he's going to do later. Okay, remember earlier when I told you that behind Jim's talking head there was a winter scene? Oh, is this the payoff? Give it to me. I want you to notice that in the background of this birthday candle scene, my cardigan is draped on the back of my chair. It's a really nice detail because if you notice
在商店里，我并没有穿它。我还想让你们知道，过一会儿在衣帽架上，你会看到帕姆那件巨大的羽绒服，也就是你后面会看到她在滑冰场穿的那件，正挂在衣帽架上，还有吉姆厚重的大冬衣也挂在衣帽架上。我看出这里的问题了。如果外面在下雪，他们为什么不带上大衣？如果外面冷得要命以至于他们那天穿着厚大衣去上班，为什么帕姆会把开衫留在办公室，只穿着一件衬衫去购物？这是怎么回事？外面到底是冷还是不冷？外面很冷。
at the store, I'm not wearing it. I also want you to know that on the coat rack in a little bit, you're going to see Pam's giant puffy coat that you're going to see her wearing later at the ice rink is hanging up and Jim's big heavy winter coat are on the coat rack. I see what's happening here. Why didn't they take their coats if it's snowing out? If it's so freaking cold that they wore their heavy coats to work that day, why is Pam leaving her cardigan behind and going shopping in just a button-down shirt? What's up? Is it cold out or not cold out? It's cold out.
到底是哪个？有人工作时出现疏忽了吧。我不知道。我不知道。我只是这么一说。好吧，大家注意，我有一个重大的发现要指出来。什么？好吧，在14分44秒时，吉姆激帕姆在
Which one? Someone's slipping on the job there. I don't know. I don't know. I'm just saying. Okay. Well, I have a big thing to point out everyone. What? Okay. At 14 minutes, 44 seconds, Jim dares Pam to make an announcement
商店的对讲机里作广播通知。因为这两个人就像青少年一样。他们玩过“吉格斯（Jinx），给我买可乐”的游戏。现在他们又敢互相挑衅在公众场合做蠢事了。吉姆和帕姆，你们到底在搞什么鬼？但你猜怎么着？帕姆做了什么？我知道。她做了什么，珍娜？我知道，安吉拉，她说，
over the store intercom. Because these two are like teenagers. They played jinx, buy me a Coke. Now they're daring each other to do stupid things in public. Jim and Pam, what's going on? But guess what happens? What does Pam do? I know. What does she do, Jenna? She I know Angela, she says,
卢克，我是你父亲。星球大战。她父亲。星球大战！她引用了《星球大战》。珍娜，你做这件事的时候知道自己在做什么吗？我知道，因为我从，你知道的，流行文化常识中知道《星球大战》电影里有这么一出。是《帝国反击战》吗？那个——
Luke, this is your father. Star Wars. She father. Star Wars! She makes a Star Wars reference. Jenna, did you know what you were doing when you did it? I did because I knew from just, you know, pop culture knowledge that there was a movie from the Star Wars movies. Is it Empire Strikes Back? That-
是的，他们在互相对决。是的，并且真相大白，达斯·维达（Darth Vader）是卢克·天行者的父亲。他说，我是你父亲。然后卢克说，不，这不是真的。我知道这个梗，但我收到了一个来自K Slackish1的粉丝提问，他想知道我做那个广播通知的片段是不是即兴发挥的。
Yes, where they're fighting each other. Yes, and it is revealed that Darth Vader is Luke Skywalker's father. He says, I am your father. And Luke's like, no, that's not true. I knew the reference, but I did get a fan question from K Slackish1, who wanted to know if that bit where I make the announcement was improvised.
所以卢克的那句台词是剧本写好的。不过，我确实即兴发挥了一点。所以当我说“对不起（I'm sorry）”对着麦克风时，那是我的一个有趣的主意，也是对电影《当哈利遇到莎莉》的一个小小致敬。所以你们还记得《当哈利遇到莎莉》里的那个场景吗，哈利和莎莉在商店里唱卡拉OK。他们在唱《Surry with the Fringe on Top》。
So the Luke line was scripted. However, I did improvise a little bit. So when I say I'm sorry into the mic, that was my fun idea and it was a little nod to the movie When Harry Met Sally. So do you remember the scene in When Harry Met Sally when Harry and Sally, they're singing karaoke in the store. They're singing Surrey with a Fringe on top.
然后哈利的 bývalý 前妻开始走过来，他停止了唱歌。梅格·瑞恩（Meg Ryan）就说，哦天哪，那是我的声音。我的声音太难听了。她对着麦克风把这些都说出来了。而哈利则说，不，我想我看到海伦了。然后梅格·瑞恩很大声地对着麦克风喊道，海伦？那个声音传遍了整个商店。
And Harry's ex-wife starts to walk up, and he stops singing. And Meg Ryan is like, oh my gosh, it's my voice. I have the worst voice. And she's saying it all in the microphone. And Harry is like, no, I think I see Helen. And then really loudly into the microphone, Meg Ryan goes, Helen? And it like goes out over the store.
我一直觉得那个桥段太搞笑了。所以我想我要对着麦克风很大声地说一句“对不起”。我不知道。我是说，可能没有人会去想它。关于你那一刻灵感的来源。我太喜欢了。我觉得太甜了。
I always thought that was such a funny bit. So I thought I'm gonna say, I'm sorry into the mic really loudly. And I don't know. I mean, probably no one would ever think about it. About your inspiration for that moment. I love that. I think that's so sweet.
我也知道你有多么喜欢《当哈利遇到莎莉》。那是你最喜欢的电影之一。女士，我上大学时，在圣路易斯（我父母当时还住在那里）和密苏里州柯克斯维尔（Kirksville，我在那里上大学的特鲁门州立大学所在地的一个密苏里州小镇）之间，开车需要三个半小时。为了打发时间，我把《当哈利遇到莎莉》录制到了磁带上。然后在我开车的时候，我在车里给自己播放这部电影。
I also know how much you love When Harry Met Sally. It's one of your favorite movies. Lady, when I was in college, I had a three and a half hour drive between St. Louis, which is where my parents still lived, and Kirksville, Missouri, which is a little rural town in Missouri where I went to college at Truman State University. And what I did to pass the time was I recorded When Harry Met Sally onto an audio tape. And then I played the movie back for myself in my car on my drive.
整部电影从头到尾的台词我都背得滚瓜烂熟。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。那是世界上最甜蜜的事情。对啊。我在录音机里录下了大卫·莱特曼（David Letterman）的开场独白，然后我会放来听
I have that entire movie memorized from beginning to end. I love it. I love that. That is the sweetest thing. Yeah. I recorded on my tape recorder, David Letterman's opening monologues, and I would play them back
他的开场独白。哦天哪！好吧，你曾说你想为深夜脱口秀工作。我想从事喜剧行业。你喜欢，是的，喜剧，深夜节目，是的。是的。啊，女士。
and listen to his opening monologues. Oh my gosh! Well, you said you wanted to work for a late night talk show. I wanted to work in comedy. You loved, yeah, comedy, late night, yeah. Yeah. Aw, lady.
听着，我们注定是最好的朋友。我们当时都在车里，听着我们从电视上录下来的东西，因为我们在磁带录音机上有一百种方法。女士，我刚收到李（Lee）发来的短信。他给我发了一张照片……这是关于你的面包吗？是的。我能下去看看吗？
Look, we were meant to be BFFs. We were both driving in our cars, listening to things we recorded off of our TVs because we're 100 on our tape decks. Lady, I just got a text from Lee. He sent me a photo of... Is this about your bread? Yeah. Can I go down and check it out?
我们能休息一下吗？他给孩子们做了三明治。我想看看他们喜不喜欢。哦天哪，他真的做了。干得好，李。但他们吃了吗？这才是问题所在。我们等会儿就知道了。
Can we take a break? He made sandwiches for the kids. I want to see if they like it. Oh my God, he did it. Way to go, Lee. But did they eat it? That's the question. We'll find out.
好了，我们马上回来。全新纯电动Can-Am Origin摩托车带你驰骋各地。街头尽显时尚动力，林道探险纵横驰骋。今天就来探索你的Origin。了解更多请访问CanAmMotorcycles.com最近我父母有很多空闲时间。起初，这挺好的。嘿，妈，你能送我去踢足球吗？当然可以。
All right, we'll be right back. The all new all electric Can-Am Origin motorcycle takes you everywhere. Sleek power for the streets, deep adventure routes for the trails. Discover your origin today. Learn more at CanAmMotorcycles.com My parents have had a lot of time on their hands lately. At first, it was nice. Hey mom, can you drive me to soccer practice? Sure can.
我们晚餐吃慢炖排骨。这太棒了。然后这就变得有点太多了。一些朋友要来家里看电影。哦，我们要看什么？我去爆些爆米花。多亏了Voila，他们可以在网上从索比斯（Sobeys）、农夫男孩（Farmboy）和朗格斯（Longos）订购我们所有最新鲜的最爱，非常可靠。
We're having slow cooked ribs for dinner. It was awesome. And then it became a lot. Some friends are coming over to watch a movie. Oh, what are we watching? I'll make some popcorn. Thanks to Voila, they can order all our fresh favorites from Sobeez, Farmboy, and Longos online, which is super reliable.
现在我父母也很可靠了。稍微有点太可靠了。Voila。你的杂货配送，就是这么简单。在加拿大蒂姆（Tim's）指定餐厅限时独家发售蒂姆全新怀旧新秀曲棍球卡，重温你最喜爱的曲棍球明星的早年时光，内含独家NHL和PWHL球员及退役传奇。快来收集全套吧。我们回来了。
And now my parents are reliable. A little too reliable. Voila. Your groceries delivered. just like that. Unwrap the early days of your favorite hockey stars with Tim's new retrospective rookies hockey cards featuring exclusive NHL and PWHL players and retired legends. Collect them all only at Tim's at participating restaurants in Canada for a limited time. We're back.
关于所有好奇的人的面包报告。太好吃了。我刚吃了一片。是吗？很好吃。我不知道孩子们会不会吃。他们到底是怎么回事？你知道吗，安吉拉？他们喜欢我做的所有其他面包。他们喜欢我的酸面包（sourdough）。他们喜欢我做的面包卷。他们喜欢我做的约克郡布丁（popovers）。不管出于什么原因，我就是无法让他们喜欢我的三明治面包。他们只想要买来的那种三明治面包。我已经试过三种不同的食谱了。今天将是我做的第三种三明治面包食谱。我不知道。
Bread Report for everyone who's curious. It's freaking delicious. I just ate a slice. Is it? It's good. I don't know if the kids are going to eat it. What is their deal? You know what, Angela? They love all of my other breads. They love my sourdough bread. They love when I make rolls. They love when I make popovers. For whatever reason, I cannot get them to like my sandwich bread. They just want store-bought sandwich bread. I've tried three different recipes. Today will have been my third sandwich bread recipe. I don't know.
面包报告送给所有好奇的人。太好吃了。我刚吃了一片。是吗？挺不错的。我不知道孩子们会不会吃。他们到底是怎么回事？安吉拉，你知道吗？他们喜欢我做的所有其他面包。他们喜欢我的酸面团面包。他们喜欢我做的面包卷。他们喜欢我做的约克郡布丁。不管出于什么原因，我就是无法让他们喜欢我的三明治面包。他们只想吃买来的三明治面包。我试过三种不同的配方。今天将是我尝试的第三个三明治面包配方。我不知道。
Or they will like it the day it comes out of the oven, but the next day, it's a no-go for them. They only want it warm out of the oven. I don't know. Shall we get back into this episode, m'lady? I think we should. Where are we? I believe that we are back in human resources. 15 minutes, 15 seconds. Kevin is talking to Toby about his skin cancer. Yeah, and this is a nice callback to season one's health care episode,
或者他们刚出炉时会喜欢，但第二天，对他们来说就不行了。他们只想吃刚出炉热乎的。我不知道。我们回到这一集好吗，女士？我觉得应该。我们在哪？我相信我们回到了人力资源部。15分钟15秒。凯文在和托比谈论他的皮肤癌。对，这是对第一季医疗保健那一集的一个很好的呼应，
because Toby's like, can you get on your fiance's health care plan? Because honestly, ours is horrible. Like, that's right. So to me, to me, it was a nice callback to the health care episode. Well, Michael comes over with a bunch of facts that are about why Kevin shouldn't be worried.
因为托比说，你能加入你未婚夫的医疗保健计划吗？因为说实话，我们的太糟糕了。就像，没错。所以对我来说，这真是一个对医疗保健那一集的精彩呼应。好吧，迈克尔带着一堆事实走过来，解释为什么凯文不该担心。
He's got some statistics. The subtext is why we can still celebrate Michael's birthday without any problem, but he's presenting it as why Kevin shouldn't be worried. Yeah. And then Toby's like, you know, kind of gives him some Toby sass. And Michael's like, why are you here? And Toby's like, I work here. Well, now Michael is gonna announce
他有一些统计数据。潜台词是为什么我们仍然可以毫无问题地庆祝迈克尔的生日，但他把它包装成凯文不该担心的原因。是的。然后托比，你知道的，有点给了他一些托比式的讽刺。迈克尔就说，你为什么在这？托比就说，我在这里工作。好吧，现在迈克尔要宣布
that they're going somewhere and it's to make Kevin feel better. There's an outing for the whole office. But of course, if you remember in an earlier scene, Michael asked Dwight if he's made all the plans for later. So this is clearly been in the works. Oh, there's a big banner when we walk in says happy birthday, Michael. Like this was planned for sure. Not by the this is clearly been in the works. Oh, there's a big banner when we walk in. It says, Happy Birthday, Michael.
他们要去某个地方，这是为了让凯文感觉好点。整个办公室都有一次出游。但当然，如果你还记得前面一个场景，迈克尔问过德怀特是否为稍后做好了所有计划。所以这显然一直在筹备中。哦，当我们走进去时有一条大横幅，上面写着生日快乐，迈克尔。就像这肯定是策划好的。不是由... 这显然一直在筹备中。哦，当我们走进去时有一条大横幅。上面写着，生日快乐，迈克尔。
Like this was planned for sure. Not by the party planning committee, by the way. Angela would not allocate funds to this. No. But Dwight had this, he had planned it. We had a fan question from Noel, Angela, because we're about to go to the ice skating rink now. And that's the big surprise
就像这肯定是策划好的。顺便说一句，不是由派对策划委员会策划的。安吉拉不会为此拨款。不。但德怀特有这个，他计划了。我们有一个来自诺埃尔的粉丝提问，安吉拉，因为我们现在要去滑冰场了。这就是那个大惊喜，
that he's taking us all ice skating. And Noel wanted to know, did you have a safety meeting about ice skating? Remember safety meeting lit candle? I'm sure we did. I'm sure there was a safety meeting about we have heavy things being held on the ice. I'm sure there was all kinds of safety meetings. Well, I know we had a medic there. And the reason that I know this is because I don't know if you remember Angela, but Mindy fell while we were shooting.
他带着我们大家去滑冰。诺埃尔想知道，你们当时有关于滑冰的安全会议吗？还记得安全会议点燃的蜡烛吗？我确信我们有。我确信有一个关于我们在冰上有重物搬运的安全会议。我确信有各种各样的安全会议。好吧，我知道我们在那儿有个医务人员。我知道这个的原因是，安吉拉，我不知道你记不记得，明迪在拍摄时摔倒了。
I don't remember that. And she hurt her knee. So you know, there's that little bit at the ice skating rink where Kelly is helping Ryan. Yeah. Well, she fell and she hurt her knee and the medic had to give her some ice, but she was able to finish filming. Her knee was okay. I thought it was interesting when you saw the different couplings of people ice skating.
我不记得了。而且她弄伤了膝盖。所以你知道滑冰场里有那么一个小片段，凯莉在帮瑞安。对。好吧，她摔倒了，弄伤了膝盖，医务人员不得不给她一些冰块，但她能够完成拍摄。她的膝盖没事。我觉得当你看到人们滑冰时的不同配对时很有趣。
In the beginning, you see Kelly and Ryan, you see Pam and Jim. I sort of just kind of go around solo, so does Dwight. We just kind of, we don't want anyone to know we're seeing each other, so we skate alone. And then later you see Ryan and Phyllis holding hands and ice skating. Yes, at 19 minutes. We had a fan catch by KP who said, I love when you see Ryan and Phyllis at the skating rink holding hands so Ryan won't fall. It's such a random glimpse into their friendship. I think Angela, they did that because Mindy was icing her knee. And what's really cute if you watch it
一开始，你看到凯莉和瑞安，你看到帕姆和吉姆。我差不多就是一个人四处滑，德怀特也是。我们只是，我们不想让任何人知道我们在一起，所以我们独自滑冰。然后后来你看到瑞安和菲利斯手拉手滑冰。是的，在19分钟时。我们有一个由KP提出的粉丝捕捉，他说，我喜欢当你看到瑞安和菲利斯在滑冰场手拉手，这样瑞安就不会摔倒。这真是对他们友谊的一个随机一瞥。我想安吉拉，他们那样做是因为明迪在给膝盖冰敷。如果你看的话，真正可爱的是
is Phyllis is so tickled. She's so tickled. It's just really cute. It's very, very sweet. And I actually, I went back after I read that comment and I watched it and it's really very sweet to see the two of them skating together. So that was an accident.
菲利斯觉得太逗了。她觉得太逗了。这真的很可爱。非常非常甜蜜。其实我看了那个评论后回去看了一下，看到他们两个一起滑冰真的很甜蜜。所以那是个意外。
I had another fan question from Live Long California. Did you and John know how to ice skate? Or did you have to learn for this episode? So here's something interesting. In this episode, Jim is kind of helping Pam on the ice. But right before we filmed this episode, I had actually been in some intense ice skating training because I was filming a movie with Will Ferrell
我有一个来自“长寿加州”的粉丝提问。你和约翰会滑冰吗？还是为了这一集你们不得不学？这里有个有趣的事。这一集里，吉姆在冰上有点在帮帕姆。但就在我们拍摄这一集之前，其实我一直在进行一些密集的滑冰训练，因为我在拍一部威尔·法瑞尔的电影，
called Blades of Glory. And, yeah, every Saturday morning for a few months, I had to go early in the morning and spend about three hours learning to ice skate. And the crazy thing is my character didn't even ice skate in the movie. I am completely pretending to not know how to ice skate in this scene on The Office because I had actually just,
叫《荣誉之刃》。而且，是的，连续几个月的每周六早上，我都得一大早去，花大约三个小时学习滑冰。最疯狂的是，我的角色在电影里甚至根本不滑冰。我在《办公室》的这个场景里完全是在假装自己不会滑冰，因为我其实刚刚，
I mean, kind of learned how to ice skate quite well thanks to this movie training. You're describing my fantasy, but all I ever wanted was to be cast in something where they're like, listen, Angela, you're going to have to learn kung fu. You're going to go every Saturday. You're going to become a kung fu master or you're going to have every Saturday, you're going to become a kung fu master, or you're going to have to learn how to throw an axe. You're going to get really good at throwing axes. Like I wanted to learn something like that, but it's never happened. Well, speaking of skating, Michael is zipping around in his hockey gear. So in the background of Michael's talking head, it's around 17 minutes, 42 seconds.
我是说，多亏了这次电影训练，我已经把滑冰学得相当好了。你简直在描述我的白日梦，我一直以来想要的只是被选中出演这样一部剧：他们会说，听着，安吉拉，你得学功夫。你每周六都要去。你要成为一个功夫大师，或者你必须每周六都去，你要成为一个功夫大师，或者你必须学习如何扔斧头。你要变得非常擅长扔斧头。就像我想学类似的东西，但这从未发生过。好吧，说到滑冰，迈克尔穿着他的冰球装备四处飞驰。所以在迈克尔的单人访谈背景中，大约在17分42秒，
There's a really great shot of that professional ice skater, Burt Lankin, who stands in for Oscar. He's doing a bunch of twirls. It's just sort of fun. You realize- Nothing with you though, Ange. I know, nothing with me. But do you realize one of the office members
有一个非常棒的镜头，是那个奥斯卡的替身、专业滑冰运动员伯特·兰金。他在做一连串的旋转。这挺有趣的。你意识到——不过没有你，安吉拉。我知道，没有我。但你有没有意识到办公室成员中
who's not on the ice is Creed? And it's because he's in the arcade playing a shoot-em-up game with a bunch of kids. Oh yes, that's right, that's right. Well, there's also that scene where Michael checks Toby into the wall. Yeah. We had a fan question from Cardinals fan,
不在冰上的是克里德？那是因为他在游戏厅里跟一群小孩玩枪战游戏。哦对，没错，没错。好吧，还有那个迈克尔把托比撞到墙上的场景。是的。我们有一个来自红雀球迷的粉丝提问，
was Toby harmed in the making of that scene? No. And if you watch closely, Steve's body never really touches Toby. Like he really, like Steve, I think because he's so good, he kind of slams into the wall and makes a noise with his arms. And then Paul just sort of falls to the ground himself. No, Steve had total control. But it's because he's such a good skater.
拍摄那个场景时托比受伤了吗？没有。如果你仔细看，史蒂夫的身体其实从来没有真正碰到托比。就像他真的，史蒂夫，我想因为他太厉害了，他有点撞向墙壁，然后用手臂制造出声音。然后保罗自己顺势倒在了地上。不，史蒂夫完全掌控着。但那是因为他是个太棒的滑冰者了。
And so he could definitely sort of show off a little bit and do all that stuff. Oh, this was for sure one of Steve's favorite film days, I think. I mean, he loved it. It had to be. He was having the best time. And also, he had the best time because Nancy Carell, his wife, in real life, shows up in this episode
所以他绝对可以稍微炫耀一下，做所有这些动作。哦，这绝对是史蒂夫最喜欢的拍摄日之一，我想。我是说，他太喜欢了。一定是的。他玩得太开心了。而且，他玩得开心还因为现实生活中的妻子南希·卡瑞尔在这集里再次出现，
again as Carol Stills, the real estate agent. She's at the ice rink. But Michael's so innocent. He's like, oh, was this for sale? And she's like, no, Michael, I can go places that aren't for sale. You know, like my kids are here to ice skate. And then he's so sweet with the kids. He's so sweet. And we sort of learned that like Michael probably could have tried to play professional hockey, but he didn't think it was a great job to
饰演房地产经纪人卡萝尔·斯蒂尔斯。她在滑冰场。但迈克尔太天真了。他说，哦，这个是待售的吗？而她说，不，迈克尔，我可以去那些不对外出售的地方。你知道的，比如我的孩子们是来这里滑冰的。然后他对孩子们太温柔了。他太温柔了。我们有点了解到，迈克尔本可以尝试打职业冰球的，但他觉得如果想要一个家庭，那不是一份好工作，
have if you want a family and that's all he wants. So it's just this theme again, that Michael just wants a family. That's what he wants. Well, you know, when he offers to pull the kids around the ice rink with his hockey stick, theme again that Michael just wants a family. That's what he wants. Well, you know, when he offers to pull the kids around the ice rink with his hockey stick, he's skating backwards and he's pulling the kids. Lee does that all the time with our kids. So when I saw that, I was like, Oh, I think that's like a hockey guy thing to do.
而这正是他想要的全部。所以这又是一个主题，迈克尔只是想要一个家庭。这就是他想要的。你知道的，当他提议用冰球棍拉着孩子们在冰场上转圈时，这又是迈克尔渴望家庭的主题。这就是他想要的。你知道，当他提议用他的冰球棍拉着孩子们在冰场里滑时，他正倒着滑冰，拉着孩子们。李对我们的孩子总是这样。所以当我看到那个时，我想，哦，我觉得那是冰球男才会做的事。
You pull your kids around as they hold onto the hockey stick. You just turned into like a 16 year old girl with googly eyes. You just thought about your husband. I wish you could have seen Jenna just now. She just literally did this weird thing with her shoulder and she kind of tossed her hair and she was like, I think it's a hockey guy. Like it was, what just happened to you? Clearly, clearly when you saw your husband do that, you're like, yeah, yeah, baby. I get real smitten with him sometimes, especially when he does, you know, when he's on the ice, fathering. Yeah.
你拉着你的孩子们，他们抓着冰球棍。你刚才简直变成了一个满眼桃心的16岁女孩。你刚才想到了你丈夫。我真希望你刚刚能看到珍娜。她刚刚字面意思上肩膀做了个奇怪的动作，还甩了甩头发，然后她就说，我觉得那是冰球男会做的事。就像，你刚才怎么了？显然，显然当你看到你丈夫那样做时，你会想，耶，耶，宝贝。我有时真的会为他神魂颠倒，特别是当他做那种事的时候，你知道的，当他在冰上当爸爸的时候。对。
On the ice being a great dad. Okay. Now Kevin gets the phone call. Everyone skates around him. Jenna, I remember filming this because we had to time it out and there were a bunch of us on the ice that skate up to where he is. Do you remember this? Yes, and we have to all be able to stop.
在冰上当个好爸爸。好了。现在凯文接到了电话。每个人都围着他滑冰。珍娜，我记得拍摄这个，因为我们需要掌握时间，我们有好多人在冰上向他所在的地方滑过去。你记得这个吗？记得，而且我们都必须能够停下来。
I didn't know how to stop. Yeah. That was my one problem. I didn't know how to stop. So I remember trying to like push really hard to slow myself down so I didn't run into people. But I was like stressed out. Well guess what? His results are negative. Which is a good thing. You want your results to be negative. But Michael doesn't understand that. No, Michael's like, damn it. Michael is gutted. He's like, oh no, this is horrible. We're gonna beat this. And he has that amazing talking head where he's like,
我不会刹车。对。那是我的唯一问题。我不会刹车。所以我记得当时极力想用力推自己来减速，免得撞到别人。但我当时压力好大。好吧，你猜怎么着？他的结果是阴性的。这是件好事。你希望你的结果是阴性的。但迈克尔不明白这一点。不，迈克尔觉得，操。迈克尔心碎了。他说，哦不，这太糟糕了。我们会战胜它的。然后他有了那个惊艳的单人访谈，他说，
it turns out that in the medical field, negative is a good thing. Now in the real world, negative means bad, but when it comes to test results, it was one of those that you love Angela, where he's describing things to us that the rest of us all know. And then one of my favorite things is when Michael is like, I'm going to break this down for you.
事实证明，在医学领域，阴性是一件好事。现在在现实世界中，阴性意味着坏事，但当涉及到测试结果时，这就是那种你最喜欢的安吉拉时刻，他向我们解释那些我们其他人全都知道的事情。然后我最喜欢的环节之一就是迈克尔说，我要给你们分析一下。
Yeah. This is what it's like information. We all know as a surprise to you too. Yeah, I know. I'm going to tell you. Yeah. Yes. Well, now we're opening gifts, lady. I know I love fill you in. It turns out. Yeah. Yes. Well, now we're opening gifts,
是的。这就是资讯。我们全都知道，对你来说也是个惊喜。对，我知道。我要告诉你。是的。是的。好吧，现在我们要拆礼物了，女士。我知道我喜欢交代一下。结果是。是的。是的。好吧，现在我们要拆礼物了，女士。
lady. I know. I love this scene. We're opening gifts. I have actually been in the room where we filmed. I'd been there before because I'd been to a kid's birthday party. And if you have a kid's birthday party at this particular rink, number one, your birthday child gets to ride the Zamboni around the ice one time. Oh, yes. And then you get to have all of your birthday cake and presents in this room where we were. So it kind of cracked me up that this is where Michael's birthday would be because he's so childlike. So we're sitting at this table. Kevin gets a card that says, get well soon or something like that. But it's got a lady in a bikini. This clearly made his day. He's gonna save that. Maybe he'll put it with some of the things
我知道。我喜欢这个场景。我们在拆礼物。其实我进过我们拍摄的那个房间。我以前去过那儿，因为我去参加过一个孩子的生日派对。如果你在这个特定的冰场办儿童生日派对，第一，你的生日寿星可以坐一次赞波尼（扫冰车）绕冰面一圈。哦，耶。然后你就可以在这个房间里吃生日蛋糕和拆礼物了，也就是我们当时呆的房间。所以这让我觉得挺好笑的，迈克尔的生日居然会在这里办，因为他太像个孩子了。所以我们坐在桌旁。凯文收到了一张卡片，上面写着祝早日康复之类的话。但上面有一个穿比基尼的女士。这绝对让他的一天都美好了。他要把那个收起来。也许他会把它和一些
he keeps on his computer, cause he's a little pervy. He's very happy about this card. He loves it. And then Michael gets a Wilkes-Barre Penguins hockey jersey from Dwight. This is a real team. It actually, well, and it says from Dwight.
保存在电脑里的东西放在一起，因为他有点色。他对这张卡片非常高兴。他太喜欢了。然后迈克尔收到了德怀特送的一件威尔克斯巴里企鹅队的冰球球衣。这是一支真正的球队。它其实，嗯，上面写着来自德怀特。
From Dwight number one, I have been to their rink, me and Craig Robinson, Brian Baumgartner, Kate Flannery for the first ever office convention. We got to go, we got to go on the ice. We all got a jersey. I still have my jersey. That's amazing. Yeah, they're the AHL team. So they're not the NHL team. They're the AHL team. So they're not the NHL team. They're the AHL team. And that's yeah, real hockey team. Real hockey team and their mascot is Tux the Penguin.
来自德怀特一号，我去过他们的冰场，我和克雷格·罗宾逊、布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳、凯特·弗兰内里为了第一届办公室大会去过。我们去了，我们上了冰。我们都拿到了一件球衣。我到现在还留着我的球衣。太棒了。对，他们是AHL（美洲冰球联赛）球队。所以他们不是NHL球队。他们是AHL球队。所以他们不是NHL球队。他们是AHL球队。那就是，是的，真正的冰球队。真正的冰球队，他们的吉祥物是企鹅图克斯。
Everyone there was really, really nice. That was, that was super fun. Well then Pam gives Michael Nightswept. From everyone. Says it's from everyone. Yeah. Yes. From everyone in the office.
那里的每个人都真的非常非常好。那真的，真的超级有趣。然后帕姆送给迈克尔“夜风”（Nightswept）古龙水。来自所有人。说这是来自所有人。对。是的。来自办公室里的所有人。
We had a fan question from Boss Lady. Is there really a cologne called Nightswept? Well this, there's not, but Jenna, did you know this is a callback? Did you catch this? Yes, yes, from Hot Girl. When they're cleaning out his car. Yes, in season one, episode six, Hot Girl, Ryan and Michael are cleaning out his car. Yes. In season one, episode six, Hot Girl, Ryan and Michael are cleaning out his car. And Michael says, that's my Drakar Noir. Right? Is that how you say that? Yeah. And Ryan's like,
我们有一个来自“老板娘”的粉丝提问。真的有一种叫“夜风”的古龙水吗？嗯，这个，没有，但是珍娜，你知道这是一个呼应吗？你抓到这个细节了吗？是的，是的，来自“辣妹”那一集。当他们在清理他的车时。是的，在第一季第六集“辣妹”中，瑞安和迈克尔在清理他的车。是的。在第一季第六集“辣妹”中，瑞安和迈克尔在清理他的车。迈克尔说，那是我的 Drakar Noir（法国古龙水品牌）。对吧？是这么读的吗？对。然后瑞安说，
no, it's Rite Aid Night Swept. And Michael's like, uh-uh, it's a perfect smell-alike. I'm not paying for the label. So he's probably very excited. He likes Night Swept and he already is a buyer of Night Swept. And here he gets a four pack. He got lotion, cologne, some kind of body spray maybe. Yes, that was all packaged and created by Phil Shea. That is a fictional cologne line. However, I just wanna let you know that I did Google Night Swept and there is a Christian based mystery novel by writer Marvin Rehm called Night Swept and
不，那是莱德药店的“夜风”（Night Swept）。然后迈克尔说，呃-uh，味道一模一样。我才不会为牌子付钱。所以他可能非常兴奋。他喜欢“夜风”，而且他本来就是“夜风”的买家。在这里他得到了一整套四件装。他得到了乳液、古龙水，可能还有某种身体喷雾。是的，那是菲尔·谢伊打包和创作的。那是一个虚构的古龙水系列。不过，我只想让你们知道，我确实谷歌了一下“夜风”，有一本由作家马尔文·雷姆写的基督教悬疑小说就叫《夜风》，
it's available on Amazon. Okay. There you have it. For super fans out there who might want to read a book called Night Swept. Night Swept. It doesn't smell like anything from what I would assume since it's a book and it's not a cologne. There you go. There you go. Where are we?
在亚马逊上有售。好吧。给你啦。给那些可能想读一本叫《夜风》的书的超级粉丝们。夜风。从我的假设来看，它什么味儿也没有，既然它是一本书而不是古龙水。就是这样。就是这样。我们在哪？
It's the end of the episode. That's it. Pam ends this episode with a talking head. She says it was a good day. Angela, because of what you said earlier, which is that, you know, finally we get a little flirty flirt for her and Jim. They got to go shopping. She got to learn he uses fabric softener.
这一集结束了。就是这样。帕姆以一个单人访谈结束了这一集。她说这是美好的一天。安吉拉，因为你刚才说的话，也就是，你知道，终于她和吉姆之间有了一点调情。他们去购物了。她了解到他用衣物柔顺剂。
I mean, this was a good day for Pam. She got to pretend what it would be like maybe to be Jim's girlfriend for a day. And... Yeah, run an errand. Run errands together, and she loved it. She loved it. So it was a good day. And Michael had a great birthday. As it turns out, he got to ice skate, he got a present he liked, Kevin was going to be okay. So it all ended well. It did.
我是说，对帕姆来说这是美好的一天。她得以假装有一天成为吉姆女朋友会是什么感觉。而且……是的，跑跑腿。一起跑跑腿，她很喜欢。她很喜欢。所以这是美好的一天。迈克尔也过了一个很棒的生日。事实证明，他去滑冰了，得到了他喜欢的礼物，凯文也会没事的。所以这一切都有了个好结局。确实。
But before we say goodbye to Michael's birthday, there is a deleted scene that I have to read. I'm not going to tell you anything about it. It's a Dwight talking head. I'm going to read it and then I'm going to just watch your reaction. Okay? All right. Okay. This is okay. Deleted scene of a Dwight talking head from Michael's birthday. Michael's birthday is hard for me because he gets very excited, but he's also under a lot of pressure, which builds up until he's ready to explode. As his right-hand man, it's my job to release that pressure so that he can enjoy himself, if only for a moment. Wow. That is brilliant. That is brilliant. That is a delightful, delightful talking head
但在我们跟迈克尔的生日说再见之前，有一个我必须读出来的删减片段。我不会跟你透露任何关于它的内容。这是一个德怀特的单人访谈。我要读一下，然后我就静静地看你的反应。好吗？好的。好吧。这个可以。来自《迈克尔的生日》中德怀特单人访谈的删减片段。迈克尔的生日对我很艰难，因为他会非常兴奋，但他也承受着很大的压力，这种压力不断积聚，直到他准备爆发。作为他的得力助手，我的工作就是释放这种压力，以便他能够享受自我，哪怕只有一会儿。哇。这太绝了。这太绝了。这是一个非常非常精彩的单人访谈，
written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky. Right? That's right in their will house. But you know it probably was hard for Rain to get through that. For sure. Guys, that's it. That's Michael's birthday. We celebrated Michael's birthday. Happy birthday, Michael. We hope you had a good time. Thanks for coming along for the ride. Next week, we're gonna do some drug testing.
由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼斯基共同编写。对吧？这完全在他们的擅长领域。但你知道雷恩要把它演完可能挺不容易的。肯定的。伙计们，就这样。这就是迈克尔的生日。我们庆祝了迈克尔的生日。生日快乐，迈克尔。我们希望你玩得开心。谢谢你跟我们一起踏上这段旅程。下周，我们要进行一些药物检测。
Dwight, why is your urine green? We'll find out. Ooh. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey Second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela
德怀特，为什么你的尿液是绿色的？我们会找到答案的。哦。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯饮品》。本期节目最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是奥德赛第二杯饮品的呈现。本期节目最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是奥德赛的呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·
Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。